Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs. This is Tim Ferriss. Welcome to
another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show. Today, we have a repeat guest,
and good Lord did his last episode do well.
It did spectacularly well. You guys loved it.
So back by popular demand is Morgan Housel.
You can find him on Twitter @morganhousel,
H-O-U-S-E-L. He is a partner at the Collaborative
Fund. His book, The Psychology of Money, which we
really dug into in depth last time, has sold more
than three million copies and has been translated
into 53 languages. Didn't even know there were
that many languages. I'm kidding, of course.
He is a two time winner of the Best in Business
Award from the Society of American Business
Editors and Writers, and winner of the New
York Times Sidney Award. I might be jealous.
I might be jealous. In 2022, MarketWatch
named him one of the 50 most influential
people in markets, good friend to have.
He serves on the board of directors at
Markel. Morgan's new book is Same as Ever: A Guide
to What Never Changes. You can find my first,
and as I mentioned before, a widely popular
interview, and very tactically dense interview
with Morgan at tim.blog/morganhousel. And
without further ado, morganhousel.com and
Morgan himself, nice to see you again.
Morgan Housel: Nice to see you, Tim.
Happy to be back. Thanks for having me.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. So let's start
with a cryptic prompt, and I'll let
you run with it, which is Buffett's
Snickers. Where should we go with that?
Morgan Housel: So after Psychology of Money,
I was really debating what to write next for
my next book. I had thrown around all these
different topics and I had some good ideas,
but it really hadn't hit me what I wanted
to write about. And I was at a retreat with
a group of investors about three years ago,
and one of the investors, he was actually a CEO
of a large public company, and he's pretty good
friends with Warren Buffett. And he told this
story that I had never heard before about Buffett,
and it's pretty rare to have a story about Buffett
that I've never heard that no one's — everybody
knows every Buffett story, but this was a new one.
And he said, the CEO said, that in 2009 during the
peak of the Great Recession when the economy was
in pieces, he was driving around Omaha with Warren
Buffett. Buffett was driving, he was a passenger,
and the CEO said to Warren, and they're driving
past closed up shops during the Great Recession,
the whole country's in tatters. And the CEO said,
"Warren, how are we ever going to pull out of
this? The country's never going to be the same
after this." And Warren said, "Let's call this
guy Jim." That's not his real name, but he said,
"Jim, do you know what the bestselling
candy bar was in 1962?" And Jim said, "No."
And Warren said, "Snickers." And Warren said, "Do
you know what the bestselling candy bar is today?"
And Jim said, "No."
And Warren said, "Snickers."
And that was the end of the conversation. He just
stopped right there. And that was his answer to,
"Is the country ever going to be the same?" And
I think if you look at Warren Buffett's success,
he has been betting on things that stay the
same forever. And it really hit me in that
moment that this was the book that I wanted to
write, because for my entire career as a writer,
I had been, "cynical" is probably the right
word, and just astounded at how bad people
are at forecasting, not just in finance,
and the stock market, and the economy,
but in politics. And it's been like that forever.
The most famous expert's ability to predict what's
going to happen next is atrocious, and
it's always been atrocious. And again,
that just made me cynical. It was just like
the whole pundit industry is a scam. That was
my view. And then it was like, "Okay, is there a
positive spin to this? How can I use knowing how
bad we are at forecasting to try to do better
at my ability to look forward in the future?"
And I think what I settled on is, people are
so bad at predicting the future because they're
always trying to predict what's going to change.
They're always trying to predict what's the next
new technology? Who's going to win the next
election? When's the next recession going to
come? And our ability to do that is zero. It's
virtually zero. But for the people like Buffett
who focus on what's not going to change,
their ability to understand the future is
actually pretty good. And so they're focusing on
parts of human behavior that have never changed,
that were true 500 years ago, that will be
true 500 years from now. And so I have no
idea when the next recession's going to come, but
I know exactly how people are going to respond to
greed and fear, because that's never changed.
There's a great quote from Naval where he says,
"If your life played out a thousand times, a
thousand different iterations of your life, what
would be true in 999 of them?" And those are the
things that you want to focus on in life because
those are not things that are guided by luck, or
chance, or just the quirky ways of the world. And
so that was, that to me was like, "Ah, I love
that framing." And it also occurred to me that
a lot of what I had been writing about for the
previous 15 years were things that never change.
I think in many ways, Psychology of Money is the
psychology of you, the individual. It's like,
"What's going through your head?" And Same as Ever
is the psychology of us as a collective. It's just
what do we keep doing as a society, as a group
over, and over, and over again? One other thing
that really struck me here that was influential
to this book for me was one of my favorite books
is a book called The Great Depression: A Diary,
and it's written by a lawyer named Benjamin Roth,
who, during the Great Depression, kept a
very detailed diary about what he saw all
over his town in Ohio that his son published.
And it's the best economics book ever written.
And during that diary, there's one diary
entry from, I think, 1932 where he says,
"What I see around the Great Depression in
1932, it reminds me exactly of what happened
in 1920 and in 1878 and in 1865." And he's like,
"It's the same forces happening over, and over,
and over again." I thought, "Oh, that's really
interesting." And then a couple pages later it
dawned on me that what he was writing in
1932 is exactly what happened in 2008.
The way that people were dealing with uncertainty
and greed and fear. It never changes. It's the
same movie over, and over, and over again. And so
if you focus on those things that never change,
I think it's our only ability to really understand
the future, your future, society's future,
the economy's future. But it's just not as
exciting as focusing on what is going to change.
all of the attention in the media focuses
on what's the next big technology,
what is going to change.
Tim Ferriss: Hence, the "news."
Morgan Housel: And so the premise
of this book is just like —
Exactly, because that's exciting and it's fun. So
the premise of this book is like, let's stop doing
that. Let's focus on what we know with certainty
is going to be a part of your future, and that's
the best that we can do to see the future.
Tim Ferriss: I've been excited to have this
conversation for a couple of reasons and I'll
edge into those by way of maybe a few anecdotes.
So one, I'm not going to get the attribution
right and I'm not going to get the phrasing
totally on point. But there was an announcement,
I think it might've been Donald Knuth, K-N-U-T-H,
but there's a blog post that I wrote some
time ago, which was ["Finding the One Decision
That Removes 100 Decisions."] And he made an
announcement when he stopped using email. Now
I'd be curious to know how well that's held
up over time. However, he said, in effect,
"I realize that I no longer want to stay on
top of things. I want to get to the bottom of
things." So that's phrasing that has really stuck
with me and maybe we'll come back to stories. And
his entire email was maybe a mini story, and had
an arc, and that has stuck with me for years now.
The second is, in the last few weeks I've
become very interested in ancient Sumer and the
dynasties in Ur and Uruk in modern day Iraq, and
looking at the birth of writing as we understand
it in cuneiform, which I never knew was cuneiform
instead of a different pronunciation. In any case,
the stories, as you listen to them in these
various podcasts, if you did a search and
replace with a handful of names, this is true
for Letters from a Stoic or the Moral Letters to
Lucilius as well from Seneca the Younger, if you
just did a search replace with some names, it's
the same set of dynamics, it's the same foibles of
human nature. It's the same consequences of fear,
greed, wrath, fill in the blank.
And my question for you is, given how
much you've thought about writing, given how much
you have written, you've written, I would imagine,
hundreds, thousands of pieces and we spoke quite
a bit about writing in our last conversation and
the fact that writing is on some level, or good
writing, at least the type of writing that we
do is intrinsically selfish. We're writing for
at least an audience of one and that I'm just
going to do a quick recap on some of the things
that stuck with me from our last conversation,
which have proven to be true again, and again,
and again, for instance, and please fact check me,
but good writing is easy, bad writing is hard.
If you're just struggling through, word by word,
the slog of a piece, chances are it's just
not going to be good. And also if you have
writer's block, there's a damn good chance
it's just a shitty idea or a mediocre idea
that you're trying to force into some
existence. Of all the things that you
could write about. How did you choose to do this,
especially after the success of your last book?
Morgan Housel: I was told many years ago by Jason
Zweig, a great friend and mentor of mine from The
Wall Street Journal that you should only write a
book if in your brain you have to do it. Not like,
"Oh, I should do it." Or, "Oh, that's a
lot of money that I could get for doing
it." Only doing it if you're like, "I can't
sleep until I get these ideas on paper."
And even in blog form, for my entire career,
that's always been the case. I'm not a sit down
at my desk at nine o'clock and publish by four
o'clock kind of person. I've always been, I'm
just going to toss around a bunch of ideas in my
head and I'm only going to sit down and write when
I can't do anything else until I get this done.
The idea is so fresh, and it's just spilling out
of me. And there's been plenty of times when we'll
be grocery shopping with my wife and kids and I'm
basically just like, "I have to go. I need to
go sit down at the computer and write this out."
And the opposite of that, if I'm like, "Oh,
I should probably write something this week,
let's force out the words," it's garbage
every single time. And so I feel like I
didn't necessarily choose to write this book. I
think I would've been really happy just stopping
at Psychology of Money and saying, "That's
great. I'm just going to quit while I'm ahead,"
which is a general idea that I really admire.
But I think it got to the point where I was like,
"I really — I have to do this." And it struck
me around. It was the early days of COVID when
this really struck me. I was writing almost every
week, almost every day, about things that never
change and putting a lot of thought into it.
And it really became a philosophy that guides
my entire life. And I think, to tell you the
truth, it relieved a lot of anxiety from my life
once I internalized a lot of these ideas, anxiety
about the future, what's my future hold? What's
the economy going to do next? During the early
days of COVID, what's COVID going to do next?
Once you admit that we have no idea, we have no
clue, we have no clue what's going to happen,
but that doesn't mean that you're giving up just
becoming a fatalist. It's just like let's shift
our attention to what we know is going to be true.
And I honestly think I became happier and calmer
and my life improved once I got to that point.
Tim Ferriss: So in a sense, is that a Serenity
Prayer applied to your life through the
lens of human nature over time? In a sense,
separating the things that you can change from the
things that you cannot, the things that you can
predict with some certainty versus the many things
that you cannot. Is that what reduced the anxiety?
Morgan Housel: I think so. And of course this
is not an idea I came up with. That's the core
of Stoicism. It's been around for 2,000 years.
It's what can you control and what can you not?
You really need to be able to figure out how to
separate those. So I'm not claiming at all that
I came up with these ideas, but once it became —
Tim Ferriss: Wait a second, you created
Buddhism and Stoicism?
Morgan Housel: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Good for you.
Morgan Housel: In 2020. It was amazing. It was
a very productive year. But once I crystallized
them and I could contextualize that in a way that
made a lot of sense to me, I honestly think
it improved my life in a pretty profound way.
Tim Ferriss: So we're going to come back
to that and we're going to come back to it
quickly. But since I am getting back into writing
and I've been experimenting with fiction largely,
but I'd like to actually write some nonfiction
blog posts in the old style back when there were
blog rolls. I want to really rewind the clock
and go retro with some of my writing, because I
do have some ideas that are so persistent that
I feel like it would be beneficial for me to
write in order to think about them more clearly.
And what we didn't cover in our last conversation
was how you draft your first drafts, or your
rough drafts. Because you have these ideas,
you're at the grocery store, you're out on a
walk, you're in the shower, whatever it might
be. What does it look like when you put first
words on paper or screen? Because that is where
I often procrastinate facing the empty screen,
the blinking cursor. What's your move there?
Morgan Housel: I first need to disclose that
what I'm about to say is probably the worst
writing advice you could give someone. So if
you are a new writer or an aspiring writer,
plug your ears and fast-forward this.
Tim Ferriss: That'll be on the headline.
"Including the worst advice for writers."
Morgan Housel: I've always been like this, and
I don't think it's a good strategy, but it's been
my strategy. I'm a first draft and publish writer.
I think the best way to write is to write a first
draft, get it done, and then go back, and edit,
and clean up, and rewrite, and whatnot.
I've always been one sentence at a time,
and when I'm done with that sentence, it's
final. So by the time I get to the bottom
of the article or the bottom of a chapter, it's
pretty much done. But that's not because I can
write a perfect first draft, it's because
I'm not going to leave this sentence that
I'm writing until it's perfect. I'm not going
to move on to the next sentence until every
word is perfect. That's always how I've been.
Tim Ferriss: I believe Kurt Vonnegut talked
about swoopers and [bashers]. I may be getting the
wording wrong, but swoopers are the vomit of first
draft refine, refined into a diamond, and then
the plodders are the line at a time, one small
facet at a time, and then they're done. I tend to
err on the side of being closer to that myself.
However, that doesn't seem to work
unless you have a clear idea of what
your structure is going to look like, or
at least of where you're going to start,
so that you're not then endlessly swapping things
around or scrapping the first half, in which case
you're edging more towards that refine, refine,
refine. So how do you figure out the structure
of a piece or what your lead is going to be?
Morgan Housel: When I start an article, or
a chapter even, I really have no idea where it's
going to go. It's not like all the ideas are in my
head and I just need to put them out on paper. And
I feel like the process of writing is the research
process for me. And so that's where the plotter
style comes in, which is I write one sentence,
and I sit there, and stare at it and it's like,
"Oh, that reminds me of this. Oh, that prompts
another thought that I had. That paragraph I just
wrote reminds me of something else I can pull in."
That's really where it comes from. So coming up
with an idea, honestly, I think most blog posts,
I start with a headline. And I'm like, "I want to
write an article called Everything is Cyclical.
Whatever it might be. And let's just run with
that. That idea, because everything is cyclical,
and I'm sure I could put together a story about
why that is and a couple examples of that. So
let's just start there and see what happens."
And I just start throwing things on the page.
And usually within the process of a blog post or
a book chapter, I'll go for three walks around my
neighborhood. And during that walk I'm a hundred
percent focused on what I'm– writing and thinking
about, "What did I just write? Is that true? Oh,
actually that reminds me of something else. So
that's always a process." If I'm sitting at my
desk, I really can't get my brain to work as
well as it is when I'm getting up and walking
around. So very often, too, if the weather's
bad outside in the middle of walking, or in
the middle of writing, I'll get up and fold
the laundry or get up and do the dishes, get up
and just walk around the house. It's just like,
I think movement is really critical to forming
new thoughts and moving the piece along,
which is so critical when you don't know where
it's going to go when you started writing it.
Tim Ferriss: So let's look at a post of yours. And
I read three in prepping for this conversation,
"Respect and Admiration," "Rich and
Anonymous," and then "Expectations
Debt." How did you decide to write "Rich
and Anonymous?" And maybe that's a way to
move into discussing some of the content,
some of the messages, some of the stories
in that piece. But how did that come to be?
Morgan Housel: "Rich and Anonymous" came to be,
because — this was probably about two years ago,
I did a consulting session with a group of NBA
athletes. Most of them were NBA rookies. And the
topic of conversation was everybody knows that NBA
athletes, all pro athletes have a very high rate
of going bankrupt. They have a three-to-five-year
career where they make tens of millions of
dollars, they blow it all, and then they're
done. Everyone knows the story. So the topic of
conversation was like, how do we prevent that?
And one of the athletes, who's 19, from the NBA,
he had very recently been drafted to deca-million
dollar contract, massive amount of money. He
brought up this fact that I thought was so astute,
particularly for a 19-year-old. And he said, "When
you grow up in inner city poverty and then you
make tens of millions of dollars at age 19, that's
not your money. That is Mom's money, Dad's money,
cousin's money, brother's money, neighbor's money,
Grandma's money. You can't just tell all of them,
'I got my money, good luck to you all' back in
inner city poverty. It doesn't work like that.'"
And he said the biggest reason that athletes go
bankrupt is not because they bought themselves a
mansion, it's because they bought their fifth
cousin a modest house and they felt so much
obligation to help them. So that was this idea
that I came up, I don't know if I came up with it,
but I called it "social debt." And I think with
every dollar that you earn comes some amount of
social debt. And for somebody like an athlete
or a movie star, there's a ton of social — for
every dollar that they earn, there's probably
$4 of social debt that comes on top of it.
And it's very easy to track your net worth,
it's incredibly difficult to track your
social debt. It's this obscure figure, but
it's always there. And even if we're not
talking about deca-million dollar athletes, I
think for the average person who gets a raise,
their salary goes from $50,000 to $55,000. With
that even comes an increase in expectations of
now they expect to live in a bigger apartment
to wear nicer clothes, to eat out more. And
just their expectation increase that comes with
that is a form of social debt that came with it.
And so that is this idea. I'm pretty sure
that Naval came up with this phrasing, too,
that the best spot you want to be in life is rich
and anonymous. The worst is poor and famous, which
was maybe Monica Lewinsky or something. Like very
famous and no money, that's the worst position you
can be in. Rich and anonymous is the best. I spent
some time with a family two or three years ago.
The family is worth $8 billion and if you Google
their name, nothing comes up. They are completely
anonymous. They're not on any Forbes list, they've
not done any interviews, they donate their money
anonymously, and that's all very intentional.
And so this family is worth $8 billion and they
have virtually no social debt. They can just
walk down the street, they can go to any cheap
restaurant. Nobody knows who they are, and they've
been very cognizant of doing that. And when I see
how happy they are and how well-balanced they are,
how well-balanced their children were, it was like
that's the spot that everyone wants to be in.
So even if you're not worth $8 billion like that,
realizing that every dollar of net worth that
you gain comes with probably at least a couple
pennies of social debt, I think is a really
important thing to think about and contemplate.
Tim Ferriss: So let me ask
you more about this family.
All right, eight billion, that's non-trivial.
So you would think that this family would be
on many radars, many lists, whether they
want to appear there or not. And I think
it's probably sector dependent. I don't want
you to share anything you don't want to share,
but there may be some sectors, there are more
sectors, that are prone to being publicly exposed,
or of public interest than others. If you're a
defense contractor, maybe the people who read
People magazine are not as interested as if
you are a movie star, or fill in the blank.
But what are some of the decisions, outside
of anonymous donations, that you think were
critical for them, or might have been part of
this plan? And then I have some other questions
related to their kids and the happiness of
their kids. Because last time we spoke about,
I'm blanking on the name of the book, but I think
it was the Vanderbilt fortune and how almost
uniformly miserable everyone was downstream of the
inflation adjusted whatever crazy number it was,
400 billion dollars or something like that.
So coming back to the question that I led with,
what were some of the decisions
or types of decisions they made
that contributed to that outcome?
Morgan Housel: What's so interesting
about this family, and of course I'm not going
to give any details to disclose who they were,
but they made their money in a very ethical
way. It's not like they're trying to hide the
fact of how they made their money. And what's also
interesting is that if I told you the name of the
company, you would know it. It's not this hidden
obscure business. You would know what it is.
But again, they've been very intentional
about doing everything anonymously,
not being part of any fundraiser gala, not —
living, actually. They actually live a fairly
good life, but it was all based around —
Tim Ferriss: I would hope so.
Morgan Housel: But it was based around this idea
of, "How do we not ruin our children?" I think
that was really it. How do we raise children who
are well-balanced and understand the world and
are not treated differently than anyone else?
Back to the Vanderbilts, which is such a crazy
story, there is this anecdote in one of the books
where one of the Vanderbilt grandchildren wants to
learn how to play soccer. So they gather up all
the servants in the mansion that they live in,
and they're like, "Go play soccer with
our kid." And they're watching it. And
the servants who are adults —
Tim Ferriss: I have to
imagine where this is going.
Morgan Housel: The servants are all just
getting their ass kicked by this eight-year-old.
They let every goal go through. No one is going
to try to take the ball from him.
Tim Ferriss: I knew it.
Morgan Housel: And of course the eight-year-old
is like, "I'm so good! I'm so good at soccer!"
So as soon as people know who you are, and
what your last name is, how much — they
treat you differently. And that's not —
Tim Ferriss: And laugh at all your dumb jokes.
Morgan Housel: Is a terrible thing. Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: [inaudible 00:28:17] all
your dumb ideas.
Morgan Housel: I don't think I've
ever talked about this before, but I've told my
wife this. In my tenure at the Collaborative Fund,
there was a period early on when I was doing
deals and I was meeting with entrepreneurs,
entrepreneurs who were trying to raise money from
the Collaborative Fund. And it was astounding
that when I was talking to an entrepreneur who
wanted to raise money, every joke that I said was
so funny. Every insight that I had was so wise.
When people want something from you, they treat
you differently, and it's not good. So this —
back to the family that I did some work with,
they wanted to move mountains to avoid that. They
wanted their children to be treated normally,
and I have so much respect and admiration for
that. And going into this, a lot of what I was
going to do was talk to the children about money.
That was my role in this experience. And if I'm
honest, going into it, I expected them all to be
spoiled little brats. And they were the opposite.
They were the most well-balanced, polite,
well-mannered kids. And what they had that
I thought was so great is a sense of anxiety
about who they are in the world. And that's
really rare for a child who grows up
with that kind of means. Most of them,
it's in their identity that "I'm special, I'm
the best, I'm the richest, I'm the smartest."
That's tends to be their identity. And these were
completely normal. If you didn't know their net
worth and you met them, you would think that they
were the children of plumbers and accountants.
Tim Ferriss: If I could pause for one second,
and I want to get into some specifics,
maybe what you took away from that,
or some of the things that they did,
if you're able to share to produce that outcome.
Now, maybe just out of the box, this family is
programmed a little differently. So we're looking
at maybe, I don't want to say reversed causality,
but we might be looking at something
that existed out of the box, so to speak,
psychologically. However, there are probably
some levers that people can pull. And this
doesn't just apply to families with $8 billion.
For instance, I grew up without very much money,
and in my neighborhood on Long Island, the family
that made 75k versus the families that made 40k
had a similar psychological dynamic. The kids
had better toys, they had bigger TV, and that
came with it, unchecked, a certain arrogance,
even though they were by no stretch close to a
family with $8 billion. The positional economics
of it were something similar. And as I think
more about kids myself, I think about this a lot
because you don't need to be in the stratosphere
economically for this to be a relevant topic, to
think about. And if you're born in the US with
your native language as English in a reasonably
safe place, you've already won a lot of lotteries,
right? So from a global perspective, you can
also subconsciously develop some pretty kind
of perverse orientations throughout the world. So
what are some things that they did or that people
can do to produce kids or bend the arc a little
bit towards kids who are less entitled and more
self-aware in the way that you're describing?
Morgan Housel: I've thought about this a lot
and it's a question I get a lot.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure.
Morgan Housel: About how do you raise
kids that don't grow up to be spoiled
little brats? And I've come to the conclusion
that the only answer is give them less money.
That's it. That's the only thing. It's
the answer that nobody wants to hear,
but I don't think there's any other way around
it. The reason that money is valuable is because
you usually have to work hard for it. If you don't
have to work hard for it becomes not that valuable
to you. In the sense of you just throw it around.
Tim Ferriss: I see. So give them less money,
not just in the sense of inheritance,
but you're saying on an ongoing basis
like allowance, toys, et cetera.
Morgan Housel: Yes. Totally. And of
course like everyone, I just kind of anchored
to my old childhood when thinking about this. My
parents. Particularly later in my childhood, they
had some means and I got very little from it. And
at the time that sucked. I looked back on it and
think that was great. That was so good because
from age 16 I learned how to be self-dependent and
I learned how to work and I learned how to do it.
There's a good friend of mine named Chris Davis
who his grandfather, Shelby Davis, is one of the
Mount Rushmore investors. He became a billionaire
in the 1980s just from picking stocks. And Chris
Davis and his cousins and siblings got nothing,
did not get one single cent from it. And his
grandfather, Shelby Davis, would tell them, "I'm
not going to rob you of the opportunity of earning
your own income." And that's the right way to
view it. And I think every cent that you give your
children, particularly your older children,
you are robbing them of that opportunity.
My wife and I think a lot about that with our own
kids, of every cell in your body as a parent wants
to say, "I want to provide for my kids, support my
kids, boost my kids, give them all the benefit."
And it's so hard to push back against that natural
mentality and say, "No, I'm going to make you do
it on your own." I'll give you one perfect example
here. I grew up ski racing. My son who's now
seven, I started taking him skiing about two years
ago. And because I'm a fairly advanced skier,
it was no problem for me on the first day to
hold him between my legs and ski down. It's no
problem for me to do that. And so that's what I
did and I thought it was the right thing to do.
"Hey, I'm going to make this easy for you.
I'll just hold you between my legs and we'll
ski down together." And my son is very physically
coordinated, very physically talented. But because
I did that, it took him about 10 sessions of going
skiing before he could do it on his own because
I babied him. What I should have done is just
strapped him in and kicked him down the slope,
said, "Go for it. Learn yourself, learn how to
fall." And if I did that, he would've gotten it
in two runs. Instead, it took him 10 sessions
to do it. And I think it's a great analogy for
what money can do to your children too. It's
so hard to do, but when you see examples of it,
I think every parent listening will understand
this. Sometimes you've just got to click
them into their skis and kick them down.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to hijack this for my
own selfish purposes for a second. I find it very
frustrating. I have found it very frustrating over
the last say, five to 10 years when speaking
to very ultra-high net worth people from a
philanthropic standpoint, if I'm fundraising for
something that is clearly high-leverage, clearly
capital efficient with good operators, but in
the nonprofit space, how many demure or pushback
with some argument along the lines of, and they
wouldn't word it this way, but compounding more
into dynastic wealth, "I'll do more good later."
Often the subtext of that is they want to give
this dynastic wealth to their kids. They will not
say that explicitly, but there's protecting of the
nest egg, so to speak, in their response. And what
I'm curious to hear from you, because you've spent
a lot of time around very, very, very wealthy
people, if you had a billion dollars of net worth,
how many kids do you have?
Morgan Housel: Two.
Tim Ferriss: Two. All right. How much would you
give to your kids versus give away before you
die versus something else? What would you do?
Morgan Housel: It's such a good question. And
of course we don't have a billion dollars,
so this is all, it's great that this is
purely hypothetical, my guess —
Tim Ferriss: I mean, it might
be greater if you had a billion
dollars, I don't know. But yeah,
it's hypothetical, so it's easy to talk about.
Morgan Housel: And this is what we plan to do.
Now, of course our kids would get the best
education. They would always have healthcare
no matter what decisions they make in life, we'd
probably pay for a great wedding and some great
family vacations. If we were billionaires, we
might say, "We'll buy you a house." And that's
pretty much it. I think that's pretty much it.
I love the idea from the book Die with Zero,
that if you're going to give your kids —
Tim Ferriss: I was just going to mention it.
Morgan Housel: It's such a good book.
It's a wonderful book everyone should
read. And a lot of the premise is if
you're going to give your kids money,
don't wait until you die at age 97 to do it.
Give your kids money when they need it in their
thirties and forties. And so my wife and I think,
our kids are four and seven, but I think about
that now. And thankfully my kids won't listen
to this episode for many more years hopefully.
Tim Ferriss: [inaudible 00:36:58]
Exploding seven-year-old demographic.
Starting young on The Tim Feriss Show.
Morgan Housel: Exactly. We don't plan to
leave them much of any death inheritance, but
to the extent that we're going to give them a
very small amount of money, we're probably
going to give it to them in their thirties
and forties when they need it the most.
Tim Ferriss: So let's continue with this
hypothetical thought exercise. Okay, so you
don't give them an excess. Let's just say
you add up all of those things and while you're
alive, God willing, you give your kids who knows,
inflation adjusted, you have a billion dollars
just to keep it simple, right? Let's assume that's
all reasonably liquid. Each of them gets two
million bucks before you kick the bucket. People
have not figured out vampire transfusions with
20-year-olds from Lithuania or whatever all the
tech billionaires are trying these days. Whatever
the latest and greatest is hasn't really panned
out. So you arc and then you come to a natural
end, that still leaves a lot left over. Again,
as a thought exercise, would you donate most
of that over the course of your lifespan? What
would be the plan for the leftover $998 million?
Morgan Housel: I'm really ashamed of this. This
is not a good thing, but it's only been in
the last two years that my wife and I have
really thought about giving money away and we
just started doing it in a very modest amount.
And for people who have done it, I think you'll
agree with this, it's actually a lot harder than
you'd think. It's actually very, very difficult
to give it away in a way that you feel like is
making a big difference and you feel great
about and is going to the right causes. It
should be easier than it is and it's not, it's
actually very difficult. I've always been most
interested in microphilanthropy, what I'll call
it. Rather than donating to a big charity, I
want to find a single mother who's struggling and
give money directly to her, that sort of thing.
And that's actually, I think, the hardest form of
charity to do. I'll tell you two examples of this
that I've had that were really profound for me.
One was, I was in New York City and I walked past,
I think it was a CVS, and there was a mother and
a child who looked like my son, who were saying,
"Can we please have some money for food?"
Because the child looked like my son,
it was like, I have to stop. I went to the mother
and I said, "Grab a shopping cart and fill it up
and you can get anything you want," which by the
way, my mother did. I saw my mother do this to
someone when I was a child, say, "Grab a shopping
cart and fill it up, no limits." We did this.
She went in into CVS. I kind of followed them
around and I said, "No, just fill the cart up."
And when they were done with it, I paid and they
just walked out. Not a thank you, not a look in
the eye, nothing. Let me make clear I was not
doing this because I wanted the attention or
because I wanted the thank you, but I wanted some
indication that I made a difference. I wanted some
information that it helped and I didn't get it.
And that's what made it really hard. And in my
heart, I'm like, I know this made a difference.
I know that kid can eat and that's why I did
it. But in anything you do in life, you want
feedback that what you're doing is working. And
in a lot of these situations, you don't get it.
And of course, people who are begging for food
for their child probably don't have the emotional
capacity to say thank you. It's not what's going
through their head. I completely understand it,
but that's what makes it so difficult. And I've
had that similar situation happen many times to do
it. So when I think about if giving away $200 is
very difficult, how do you give away 998 million?
Or if you're Bill Gates and Warren Buffett,
how do you give away 200 billion? Very, very
difficult to do. Extremely difficult to do. I
mean, I think the best analogy for this is really
what the federal government is is a giant charity
program with the exception of defense and whatnot.
That's kind of what it is. And it's not very well
run. Most people don't like how it's run because
it's so difficult to do and make everybody happy.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, totally. I mean, if
your options are, as somebody put it to me,
I've been asking a lot of people this question
because to emphasize, again, this might seem like
rarefied air and people are like, come on, why are
we talking about a billion dollars? Number one,
because it's sort of a large, absurd amount of
money and unwieldy for the reasons that you just
described. Although I think a lot of people
who are in that upper echelon let perfect be
the enemy of good, right? They want to do more
homework and do more diligence, and they could
do a lot of good sooner on compounding problems,
but they put it off because they're hoping for
perfect information that will let them pick
the winning stocks of all the nonprofits,
which I think is very challenging to do,
and often just a means of postponing things.
But they said, "Look, your options are taxes to
the US government, your kids, or charity. Which
would you prefer?" And like you said, I mean look,
I pay taxes like everybody else, but it's not
always the best run. So would you prefer it to go
there? Would you prefer it to go to a nonprofit or
a set of nonprofits of your choosing?
MIDROLL?
But let's zoom out, because I want this to apply
obviously to more people. Mentioned the Stoics
a little bit earlier. Seneca the Younger,
who's a very controversial figure for a lot
of good reasons, but he's a hell of a quote
machine. He's like the Arnold Schwarzenegger
one-liner of the Stoics. He said, "People talk
of having riches when often riches have them,
much like a fever." And this is paraphrasing, but
of course we're all paraphrasing, it's translated,
it wasn't published in English. But how would
you suggest people think about money or income
and happiness? This has come up on the podcast
quite a lot, but this is something that comes
up in human history even more often. What are
some patterns or takeaways or lessons learned
from your observation and study of these things?
Morgan Housel: One thing that I think is really
true, and it's coming out a lot more in
the data is that if you are already happy,
gaining more money will probably make you
happier. But if you're already kind of depressed,
gaining more money is probably not going to
help that much. There's a really interesting
documentary about J. Paul Getty, who used to be
the richest man in the world. I think that the
interview is taking place in the 1960s or 1970s in
his castle in England, and it is a bonafide castle
straight out of a fiction book. And he's sitting
there in this 700-foot-long dining room surrounded
by gold and diamonds, the most ostentatious
thing you can see. And the interviewer says,
"Who are you envious of?" And the interviewer
says, "Obviously everyone's envious of you. Who
are you envious of?" And the guy, he's so morose,
he's so glum, and he just kind of looks down
and he says, "People who are happier than me."
And it was like, that's the case. Money didn't
help him because he was already depressed. And in
that situation, it's not going to do much. But I
think if you are the kind of person who already
has a chipper disposition, you're already happy,
then gaining more money will probably improve
your life. That I think is kind of an unfortunate
irony because so many people who are depressed
will think to themselves, "If only I had money,
it would fix everything." And it's probably not
the case. There's a really great quote in Will
Smith's biography where he says, when Will Smith
was poor and depressed, he could say to himself,
"If only I had more money, everything would be
better." And then when he was rich and depressed,
he didn't have that hope anymore. Money actually
subtracted the hope from his life because he
realized there was nothing else to strive for.
So I think that's the case. If you're already
depressed, that's who you're going to be when
you're rich. And this is just highlighting
something that a million people have said and
everyone already knows, is that money just
accentuates who you are. If you're a jerk, it's
going to make you more of a jerk. If you're happy,
it's probably going to make you happier.
Tim Ferriss: It's like power or alcohol
or many drugs. It's an amplifier.
Morgan Housel: Exactly, exactly. And one
of the things that's really interesting to me,
the new biography of Elon Musk, Walter Isaacson
is interviewing Musk's first wife, whose name is
Justine, and she met Elon in college before he
was any successful. He was just an immigrant
from South Africa. He didn't have any money,
no success. That's when she met him. She
talks about how much money and fame changed
him. It just completely altered his personality.
The other thing that I've always found interesting
is that if you go back and look at an interview of
Donald Trump in the early 1980s, there are several
of them you can find on YouTube when he was known
but not famous, and he was probably wealthy but
not rich, you would not recognize him. Utterly
different person, very calm, very measured,
very reasonable. And even if you are a huge
Trump fan, I think you would be stunned at who
the person is on camera. So any of us, me, you,
anyone, if we came into that level of fame and
power and money, it would change us. And there's
another quote from J. Paul Getty where he says,
"Nobody would be the same if they could afford
to be different." And I think that's a sad quote,
but I think there's a lot of truth to that.
Tim Ferriss: Say it again.
Morgan Housel: He says, "Nobody would be the
same if they could afford to be different."
Tim Ferriss: What do you think he meant by that?
Morgan Housel: I think he was probably mentioning
in the sense of does money make you happier? Does
money change who you are? And I think all of us
want to imagine that if you and I stumbled across
a billion dollars tomorrow, we would be the same
people. We would have the same friends, the same
interests, the same hobbies, the same disposition,
the same personality. And I think there's enough
examples of this where the answer is we would
not, I think there are probably some exceptions
that we could think of, but I think every single
person who comes into that kind of money is a
different person, becomes a different person,
is going to have a different personality.
Tim Ferriss: Become a different person or if
it's similar to the quote, I wish I could recall
the attribution, but, "Adversity doesn't build
character, it reveals it." I wonder if it's kind
of like watching someone with money interact with
a waiter or a waitress who's having a tough first
day or a busy section. When people don't need
to be nice anymore, how do they behave? Whereas
when you're still in building mode on some level,
especially if you're socially aware, you're
playing, I shouldn't say all people. Most
people are going to play the game consciously
or subconsciously, be on better behavior. But
when you really have fuck you money, how
often do you actually say "Fuck you?"
I think that's maybe a measure of what was
a kernel of the personality or the hidden
personality, the better hidden personality
beforehand. Also, but I don't want to end
on basically, if you think your life sucks
now, it doesn't matter what money you make,
you're probably going to still think your
life sucks. Now, even if it's true, it's
sort of a sour note to end this chapter of the
conversation on. So I want to explore it a little
bit further, but what were you going to say?
Morgan Housel: I was going to say I was in Omaha,
Nebraska last week. Obviously, Warren Buffett's
hometown, and I was driving along the freeway
and there's a giant building, one of the tallest
buildings in town that on top of the building in
enormous, probably 50-foot letters says, "Buffett
Cancer Research Center." So he's funded it,
he's bought it. Warren drives by past that
building every day and sees that. And there
is no way that seeing your name on something
like that, there's no way that he's the same
Warren Buffett who drove past that building
when he was 13. It's going to completely change
just your view of who you are in the world.
To your point about, let's not leave this on a
sad note, because you're right, I do think money
can be used to give yourself a better life. The
distinction we need to make is the distinction
between happiness and contentment. Does money buy
happiness? I think that answer is pretty firmly
no. Can money buy contentment? I think that's a
pretty firm yes. And that's great, contentment
is a great trait that makes your life better,
but it's very different from happiness.
Tim Ferriss: Could you just define that
term so we understand what we're talking about?
Morgan Housel: I would say happiness is you wake
up grinning ear to ear. Happiness is you're out
at a bar with your friends. Happiness is you hear
the funniest joke you've ever heard, and that's
what I think people strive for and they think that
money's going to give to them and it won't. But I
think contentment is you just wake up with a low
or virtually no level of anxiety. You're like, I'm
good. I'm pretty happy — I'm pretty satisfied with
my career. I'm satisfied with my relationships.
I'm satisfied with the house that I live in.
That's not happiness though. I think money can
reduce the number of sad days that you have,
but it's probably not going to increase the
number of happy days that you have. Now,
that's awesome. If you can do that, that's a
huge life improvement, but it's not happiness.
Tim Ferriss: Unless you have standup comedy
budget and you go to more standup comedy shows.
Morgan Housel: See, that's actually a great point.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not really kidding. That's
something that I do quite a lot of.
Morgan Housel: I've been on such
a comedy binge lately, just Netflix
specials. And I've said this many times,
but I think comedians are the only good thought
leaders because when you listen to good comedy —
Tim Ferriss: They're the only
practical philosophers left.
Morgan Housel: Exactly. And not only do you
laugh, but you get smarter. I think George
Carlin was a bonafide genius. I think Bill
Burr is a genius. Those guys understand human
behavior better than any psychology PhD does.
Tim Ferriss: So let's take a hard left from
what we're talking about. Let's talk about
avalanches. I'll let you take the baton and
go from there. Avalanches scare the living
hell out of me. I do have a decent amount,
I have no expert skier to the extent that
you used to compete and so on, but I have
done in the last handful of years, quite a
lot of side country and back country skiing,
and this just scares the wits out of me, does
not get less scary with each passing year. So
tell me about your experience with avalanches.
Morgan Housel: So I grew up as a competitive
ski racer in Lake Tahoe, and most of those big
years were when I was a teenager, 16, 17, 18.
And my friends and I, there were about a dozen of
us on the Squaw Valley ski team, and we skied six
days a week, 10 months a year, we skied all over
the world, always traveling around. And one day,
this is February of 2001, I was 17 years old
at the time, and Lake Tahoe where we lived, had
just been dumped on, just got an absolute monster
blanket of snow, dumped on. And the layering of
snow was very important to the story. So at one
point, Squaw got about two feet of very light,
fluffy snow. And then after that it got about
two feet of very wet heavy snow on top of that,
which we didn't think about this at the time,
but that creates a textbook perfect avalanche
condition because you have heavy snow on
top of light snow, it slides very easily.
So one day in February 2001, myself and two of my
friends, Brendan Allen and Bryan Richmond, were
skiing and we would ski out of bounds at Squaw
Valley. We would duck under the ropes that say,
"Do not cross," to ski the untouched, untracked
parts of the mountain that are so much fun to
do. And when you do that, there's no chairlift
at the bottom. We would ski to the bottom and
then hitchhike back once we got spit out on a
back country road. The three of us did this run
on the backside of Squaw. We had done it maybe a
half dozen times before, not that often because
it's such a pain in the ass to hitchhike, but we
skied down. It was so great, it was so awesome.
And halfway down we triggered a small avalanche
and it was pretty small. It came up to our knees.
And it's the most bizarre feeling because you
very suddenly have no control at all because
rather than pushing on the snow to gain traction,
the snow's pushing you. So all of a sudden you go
from skiing to I'm on a roller coaster is
how it feels. But it ended pretty quickly
and we got to the bottom. And I remember saying
to Brendan, I remember saying like, "Holy shit,
did you see that avalanche?" We laughed about it
and we hitchhiked back and didn't say another word
about it. We get back down to Squaw and Brendan
and Bryan say, "Hey, let's do it again." And I
have no idea why, but I said, "I don't want to do
it again." I think hitchhiking kind of freaked me
out. But Brendan and Bryan said, "Okay, we're
going to do it again." And I said, "Hey, rather
than hitchhiking, I'll drive my car around and
pick you guys up so you don't have to hitchhike."
So we went our separate ways. Brendan and
Bryan went and did the run again. I went down,
took my boots off, drove around to pick them up.
And when I got to the spot where I was going to
pick them up, they were not there. And I didn't
think that much about it. I thought maybe they
had already hitchhiked back. I think I was late.
So I was like, I felt bad that I was late picking
them up. And they had already left. And I drove
back to our locker room and they weren't there
either. And no one had seen them. And this was
before cell phones, but prior to cell phones,
people were very comfortable being out of touch,
unlike they are today. If you didn't know where
someone was, it was like, yeah, whatever. They're
somewhere else. I didn't think anything of it.
And later that day, Bryan's mom called me and she
said, "Hey, Bryan didn't show up for work today."
And she also just spoken to Brendan's dad.
And Brendan missed a dentist appointment that
afternoon. And she said, "Do you know where they
are?" And I said, "Yeah, we skied the backside of
Squaw, which we were not supposed to do, was
out bounds, and I was going to pick them up,
but they never showed up and no one's seen them
since." And Bryan's mom, who's an expert skier,
said, "Oh my God." And she clicked the phone,
she hung up. And I think in that moment,
both of us figured out what happened without
saying it. Both of us knew what happened. And
the day went on, we called the police, we got
a missing person's report. The police didn't
take it seriously at all. But eventually that
evening we got search and rescue involved and
they went out, it was still a blizzard.
They had a team of search dogs and these
giant floodlights to search for them. And the
next morning, about 9:00 a.m. the next morning,
the search dogs had honed in on a spot in the
avalanche field and rescuers with these giant
pro poles to probe the snow found Brendan and
Bryan buried about six feet down from a massive
avalanche. The rescuers had just said it looked
like half the mountain had been torn away. And
they were dead, of course. And so I was 17. That
had a huge profound impact on my life. This is
not that unique of a story. Everyone has lost
somebody close to them. Everyone's had a near
death experience themselves. But this was my
version of that, and it shredded me, completely
tore me to pieces. And it wasn't until years later
that I had pieced together a couple of takeaways
from this that impacted my life personally.
One was my decision to not go on the second
run with them was completely thoughtless and
brainless. I didn't weigh the pros and cons. I
didn't say, "Oh no, it's too dangerous." I didn't
think anything of it. I think I was probably just
tired. And I said, "You guys go do another
run. And I won't." If I had went with them,
100 percent chance I would've died. So the most
important decision that I ever made in my life,
it was not where to go to college. It was not whom
to marry. The most important decision I ever made
in my life was to not go on the second run with
them. And I put no thought into it. It was a
complete random fluke. And so one of the takeaways
there for me was just like how fragile life is.
There's this great quote from Tim Urban, who
I think has probably been on your show before,
where he says, "If you had a time machine and
you can go back in time, you would be terrified
because you would realize that the tiniest little
know-nothing decision that you make can flourish
into completely change your life in good ways." In
good ways and bad. Like most people, how they met
their spouse was a complete random fluke that
ended up really important to them. And so you
realize this is how incredibly fragile life is and
how there might be a decision that you make today,
that I make today, that we think nothing about.
It's the random decision that goes on to change
everything. So that story, that experience had
a profound impact on me on thinking about risk,
thinking about the tail end consequences
of risk, thinking about how fragile the
world is. It went on to impact virtually
everything in my life from that one day.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so sorry, obviously, for the
loss of your friends. And the story for all the
reasons you described is terrifying not just
from the avalanche perspective, but from the
angle of looking at how small decisions can have
huge impacts. And also how I think as we discussed
in the last conversation, risk is what's left
when you've thought of everything else. Now in
this particular case, I suppose if you'd really
taken a moment to sit down with the pro and cons,
you probably would've figured out that it was
a bad idea. But in the moment, you could have
very easily made the wrong decision.
I suppose part of what I'm wondering,
because you've become very good at interrogating
the world and your own thoughts with questions. In
that particular moment, you made a snap judgment.
It's not really a snap judgment. You made a
snap decision that saved your life, but you have
questions that you seem to explore or revisit with
some regularity. Some of them we discussed in the
last interview, but I'm just going to read a few.
So what are we ignoring today that will seem
shockingly obvious in a year? Which of our
current views would change if our incentives
were different? And it goes on and on. I mean,
there are many others. I mean, there's one that I
had not heard before, which is what hassle are you
trying to eliminate that's actually an unavoidable
cost of success? That's pretty interesting to me.
Who has the right answers, but we ignore because
they're not articulate? What looks unsustainable
that is actually a new trend we haven't accepted
yet? So my macro question about these questions is
how you arrived at these questions, whether it was
coming up with them or borrowing them or adapting
them, and which of these might be worth exploring
as our next chapter in this conversation?
Morgan Housel: I think maybe the core of a lot
of these questions is that everybody, including
myself, thinks that their experience in life is
roughly how the world works without realizing
that their experience in life is so very unique
to their life. And so you and I are white American
males, and I think it's common for us naturally
to think that the experiences that you and I have
had and how people treat us is how everyone else
is treated. And of course, that's not true. And
so I think when you accept that the world that
I've experienced is so different from the world
that you've experienced and other people, then
I think you just start asking these questions
about what else is out there that I haven't seen
that I'm oblivious to. And the fact is that I and
you and everyone is oblivious to 99.99 percent of
the world, completely oblivious to how it works
because we're centered on what we've experienced.
So that's where a lot of it comes. I think a lot
of it too, and this is an unhealthy mindset, but
I spend 99 percent of my life thinking about the
past and contemplating the future. The worst
thing that you can do, like virtually never
present. So I think I'm constantly interrogating
the past of what could it have been? Why did that
happen? What would my life have been like
if that happened? My parents were visiting
us just last week, and my mother was and is at
a very high risk of breast cancer. By age 42,
she was the oldest surviving female in her family,
her sister and mother, her grandmother, everyone
had died of breast cancer. And my mother is now 70
and she's healthy. Fingers crossed, knock on wood.
But we were talking the other day about when we
were growing up and myself and my siblings were
children, that my father and mother would cry. If
my mother had a lump that needed to get checked
out, they would hold each other and cry about
this is going to be the one. And it's so bonkers
for me to contemplate if my childhood had ended
up differently and it so easily could have, not
only could it have, it probably should have,
statistically she should have died of breast
cancer 30 years ago. And the fact that it didn't
— so I actually spent, this is probably unhealthy,
but I spent a lot of my time contemplating what
would life have been like if my mother died when
I was 10 years old? I'll take that back. I think
that is a pretty healthy thing to think about,
to imagine a life that's different than it could
have been. Because I think it prepares you for
a more variant future than you're expecting.
And the truth is that nothing would've been
the same. I would've gone to different schools.
I would've had different friends. I would've
had a different mindset. I would've had a
different career if that had happened. And
you can say that for a billion different
things in life. And then you realize that
the path that got you to where you are today
was completely unforeseeable and completely
random. And in many ways outside of your control.
Everyone, I think particularly successful people,
want to think that their success was entirely,
if not overwhelmingly, due to the decisions that
they made. And I think in virtually any
condition, in any example, that's not the
case. There were good decisions that you made —
Tim Ferriss: Very fragile framework, right?
Because you're then either excellent or terrible
depending on the outcome. And in both cases,
you're not factoring all of the chance
involved. It seems to be a fragile
mindset in a sense. It's a vulnerable mindset.
Morgan Housel: There's a German philosopher whose
name I'm forgetting, but he has this idea,
and this is probably a pretty common idea,
I don't know if he came up with this, but
he just talked about it, that there are an
infinite number of possible worlds, an infinite
number of ways the world could have turned out,
and we just happen to live in this one. There are
just an infinite number of alternative histories.
It could have gone another way. During the
Revolutionary War in the United States,
it was the Battle of Long Island, and George
Washington and his troops were very close to
being wiped out by the British. All the British
had to do was — they basically had them cornered
just outside of Brooklyn, and all they had
to do was sail up the East River and it would
all have been over, and that was their plan.
And George Washington's troops were starving
and hungry and they were whipped. And the night
that the British were planning to sail up the
river and corner him, the winds changed direction
and turned the other way and they could not sail
up the East River. And that gave George Washington
and his troops just enough time to get away. David
McCullough, who was one of the world's foremost
authorities on this topic, was interviewed by
Charlie Rose, and Charlie Rose said, "If the
winds were blowing the other direction that night,
would there have been any United States?" and
David McCullough said, "Absolutely not." The
entire reason this exists is because the winds
in Brooklyn changed directions last night. When
you hear enough stories like that, you realize
literally nothing is certain about the future.
It could all go in any different direction for
the tiniest little reason, not a big reason,
but, for me, it was not going on a second
run, and I thought about it afterwards. I had
probably been on something like 3,000 runs with
Brendan and Bryan over the course of my life,
probably something in that neighborhood. And how
many times did I say, "Hey, you guys do another,
I'm going to skip?" Probably never. I think
it was probably the first time I had done
something like that. And so, when you hear
a story about the winds changing direction,
for me, it just makes you so incapable
of having any confidence that we know
what the future's going to bring for any of us.
Tim Ferriss: Let's maybe shift to the meta level
one more time, and I'll make it more specific
in terms of the question about the questions,
and then I want to segue to, not in a rush, but
asking about perhaps things that are more inside
of our control in terms of coming back to the
Serenity Prayer, which you so kindly invented
in 2020, although I guess the Be Here Now,
you did not, that was from the canon in terms
of the past and the future, in any case.
Morgan Housel: Still working on that one.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. These questions, like
what are we ignoring today that will seem
shockingly obvious in a year, were these
questions that you generated or used mostly
in thinking about investing? Are these prompts
that you came up with for writing or something
else? Where did these questions come from?
Morgan Housel: Let me start with that specific
question about what's going to be shockingly
obvious in a year. I remember, I forget who it
was, but in the dark days of COVID, so March or
April 2020, and somebody tweeted, I forget who it
was, but they said, "In one year, we're either
going to be in the second Great Depression,
and it's going to be so obvious that that was
where we were heading, or we're going to be in
a giant boom, and it's going to be so obvious
that that's where we were heading." Either of
those outcomes would be so obvious. And the
truth is, one year later, by most measures,
we were in a giant boom, stock market boom. Things
were exploding in 2021, the meme stock bubble.
And, for a lot of people, it was so obvious. The
Fed printed all this money. We did $6 trillion.
Anyone could have seen this coming, but the
truth is that, if we were in the second Great
Depression, it would've been just as obvious.
Most of these questions that I posed in the end
of the chapter there are questions that I think
are impossible to answer. What is going to be
shockingly obvious today, one year from now,
in 2024? I think it's impossible to answer,
but it's going to be shockingly obvious. And
maybe the answer will be who is going to win or
who's going to lose the presidency? And when it's
going to happen, it's going to be so obvious. A
lot of people did this with Trump in 2016. When he
won, they said, "Yeah, I saw this coming." Maybe,
or if he had lost huge, that would've been obvious
too. Most of these questions I just have in my
semi-depressive walks around the neighborhood
sometimes, when I'm walking my dog, contemplating
what the past could have been or what the
future's going to hold for me, but I actually
enjoy doing these things. I think it's fun to
contemplate a world that is so outside of your
little comfort bubble of what you've experienced.
Tim Ferriss: Let me touch on another one of the
questions, which is which of our current views
would change if our incentives were different?
And I want to tie it to another line that I have
in front of me that I want you to elaborate on,
and maybe these parallel, maybe they
don't, but they seem like they could,
and it is the most valuable personal finance
asset is not needing to impress anyone.
Morgan Housel: I'll tell you what is so stark to
me about the topic of incentives, about how would
I be different if my incentives were different,
one of the passages that I've read that stuck out
to me the most and stopped me dead in my tracks
was from this book on World War II, as we were
just saying, it's a book called What We Knew, and
it's a book that interviews German civilians who
are around during Nazi Germany. And the book just
asks, "What did you see? What did you know during
this period? Did you know about the Holocaust?"
in a very nonjudgmental way, because they're all
civilians, "Just tell me what you saw." And
there's a German civilian who mentions that,
when Hitler came to power, virtually every
German supported him. And the interviewer says,
"Why? What was so appealing?" And the civilian
says, "Well, you have to understand, in 1920s
and the early 1930s, the German economy was an
utter catastrophe," way worse than the Great
Depression that we had in the United States.
They had hyperinflation, everything fell to
pieces. I'm simplifying this, but Hitler came
to power and said, "I have a better way. I'm
going to give you all jobs. I'm going to make you
all wealthy again. We're going to restore German
pride and power." And, in that situation, when
everyone was literally starving and had nothing,
this civilian said, "If someone comes
along and promises you a better way,
you accept it and you say, 'Yes, I'll go with
you.'" And they said everyone was so willing to
overlook the obvious downsides of Hitler because
he gave them the incentive to be like, "Hey,
do you want a job? Do you want prosperity? I'm
the way," and they said, "Sign me up, I'll do it."
There's another example. It was a documentary
in Mexico where El Chapo, who was, of course,
one of the most ruthless, murderous drug lords of
all time, but he's actually very well-supported by
a lot of local communities in Mexico, and
this interviewer had asked these people,
"Why? Why do you support this murderous dictator?"
And they said, "Well, you got to understand,
we have nothing. We have no money." And Chapo
comes to town and he says, "I'll build you homes.
I'll give you healthcare. I'll give you food.
I'll give you jobs," takes care of all of them,
and their incentive, the civilians' incentive
is to say, "This guy's great. Love this guy."
I think a lot of society, when you look at why
was Hitler supported, why is Chapo supported,
can at least in part be explained by those people
have incentives that you and I don't. And what is
scary, but undoubtedly true, is contemplating
whether you or I, if we lived in Germany in the
1930s, or if we lived in Mexico in the last
20 years, would've supported those people.
Tim Ferriss: Of course you would've.
Morgan Housel: Yes, I think you are
fooling yourself if you say, "No, I would
not have." And so I think, if you have a
cynical view of everyone who lived in Germany
was a monster, of course, a lot of them were,
but if you say they all were monsters,
everyone who supports El Chapo is a monster,
I think if your conclusion is that if all of them,
you are misunderstanding the power of incentives
and how you would be different yourself.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. I agree. Let's use that
as a segue to maybe the unrelated,
maybe the related, the most valuable
personal finance asset is not needing to
impress anyone. Is that something you can
cultivate or is that also a preset out of the box?
Morgan Housel: I think there are definitely people
who are more insecure than others, and I think
where a lot of this comes from is that everybody
wants respect and admiration from people around
them, particularly the people who they want to
admire them, their friends, their spouses, their
coworkers, and there's a couple of different ways
to cultivate that. If you can cultivate respect
and admiration through wisdom and intelligence and
humor and love and empathy, then you can get all
of it from that. If you don't have any of those
traits, most people will resort to trying to gain
admiration with horsepower and square footage,
and they'll just try to show off to other people.
I can't gain your respect with humor and wisdom,
but look at my car. It's really cool, isn't
it? That's a lot of where it comes from.
And we were talking about comedians before Louis
C.K., I'm fine saying this because I think he
would admit to it, he looks like a fat slob.
Nobody cares because he's so funny. He doesn't
need to show off his six-pack. If he drove a
Honda Civic, nobody would care. They admire
him because he's funny. And I think there's
a lot of insight in that, that everybody just
wants respect and admiration. I know there was a
picture of Justin Bieber the other day, and he's
wearing a dirty wife-beater and ripped sweatpants,
doesn't matter. He's Justin Bieber, he can do it,
does not matter. If you gain your respect and
admiration from other ways, you don't need to show
it off. And so I think that's a big part of this.
And for the huge majority of people, the biggest
financial liability that they have, it's
not student loans, it's not a mortgage,
it's their desire and their need to impress
other people. And I think that the way that
you can cultivate this is realizing
that those people are, A, by and large,
not paying attention to you. They're worried about
themselves. The people who you think are looking
at your car are not. They're thinking about their
own car. That's a big part of this, or the other
part of it is there's probably seven people in my
life who I want to love me, my parents, my wife,
my kids, one or two friends that I would say I
really desperately want them to love me. It's
really important that they love me and that's it.
The other 7.99999 billion people on the planet,
maybe I would like you to like me, but that's
about it. Once you realize that, then it's like
I want seven people to really respect and admire
me, and I'm going to put all my effort into that,
and everyone else, I really don't have much
care about. I think, once you accept that,
that's a huge relief off your shoulders.
Tim Ferriss: You mentioned earlier the most
important decision of your life being that snap
decision to not take the extra run. Very quickly,
either just before or just after you mentioned
that, you talked about marriage or who you marry.
How would you suggest people think about
that, if there is a way to think about it,
or is it just a crapshoot? It's just like,
hey, look, you're in the casino and either
you're going to roll lucky sevens or you're not,
but best of luck to you. Is there a structured
way to think about this, or a particular way, a
mode of thinking about this, that you could — any
suggestions? Asking for a friend.
Morgan Housel: Gun to my head, Tim,
it's the latter. I think a lot of it is there's a
tremendous amount of luck that's involved in it.
A lot of that is because most people want to get
married during a pretty narrow window of their
life. From probably age 25 to 35 is when most
people want to get married. During that window,
you're really just like, "Who am I meeting?"
And, particularly as you get older, a lot of
people are like, "I really want to get married.
I just met this guy," or this girl. "Okay,
that's what I got. That's what's in front
of me. That's what we're going to do." I
do think there is a sense, though, that a lot
of people, particularly when they're young,
particularly in their early to mid-twenties, are
obviously maximizing for the wrong variables. Guys
are maximizing for beauty and women will
tend to maximize for money and prestige.
That's a very generalized statement that is not
black and white. If you're offended by that,
I'm not talking about you. But, obviously, what's
going to work in the long run is just are you best
friends with this person? That's it. That's it.
I think there's analogy to investing here where a
lot of investors want to maximize for the variable
how do I earn the highest returns this year? And,
in many ways, that is like maximizing for beauty.
It's super fun. It's super exciting right now. I'm
going to get a lot of dopamine right now, which
is what you'll get from an attractive spouse,
and it's what you'll get from owning a meme stock
in 2021. But what actually works in the long term
is owning a boring index fund for 50 years, and
what's actually going to work in marriage is
marrying your best friend, even if they're not the
most attractive or richest person that was in your
social circle. I think that's really clear as day.
Now there are some people who will marry their
best friend who is also very wealthy
and very — of course, it works out,
but I think a lot of it is just is just people
maximizing for the wrong variables in there. When
I look at my own marriage, my wife and I met when
she was 19 and I was 21, so we were very young.
We were in college. And we've been together for
17 or 18 years now. And when I look back at it,
I think it was overwhelmingly luck. And I
think the biggest element of luck in there
is that we grew together and, hey, by the way,
I'm going to say we've grown together so far,
fingers crossed that we continue to do so, but if
you understand what happens to most relationships,
it's much more difficult than you would
think. But I attribute that a lot to luck.
And there were periods in our relationship when
I started to go one way and she started to go
another and we came back. But you can see it.
Tim Ferriss: How did you do that? Maybe you
don't have to give a concrete example if it's not
comfortable, but this is a relationship breaker.
That divergence breaks a lot of relationships,
or it just causes an incredible amount of strife,
and it's not clear that the lines come back
to converge. I've seen many seemingly great
relationships self-immolate because of this
divergence that does not converge in time to
save the relationship. What did you guys do
to rein it back in, or what happened there?
Morgan Housel: The best definition I've
heard about love is you love someone
if you respect them for their faults
as much as you do their good traits,
and I think that was really true, that in —
Tim Ferriss: What does that mean though? It
sounds good. I'm going to push back a little hard,
because I'm not like, "Yeah, this person's always
late. I really respect that they're always
fucking late when they show up to dinner."
Morgan Housel: No, I totally understand what you
mean, and I think maybe respect is the wrong word,
but it's more acceptance.
Tim Ferriss: I see.
Morgan Housel: If my wife does something that
irritates me, and of course, that's happened,
and vice versa, more so vice versa, I have to go
out of my way, but I try to go out of my way to
say, "I know she means well. I know she's doing
the best she can," even if it really bothered
me. And I think, if you can hold onto that, it's
easier not to look over things, but to compromise
on things. Everyone knows the friendship with
your best buddy, not your spouse or your mate,
but your best buddy, that all it takes is for
one person to pick up the phone and give you
a call. And if you can do that, you can keep a
friendship going for 20 years, 30 years. And I
think, if one person in the relationship really
wants us to work, you can really make it work.
I have a close friend who their relationship
is not that healthy, and they've said that,
at any given time, one of them wants to leave,
but there's never been a time when both of
them want to leave, and that's why they've stuck
together. And so I think, if there's one person
in the relationship that is willing to compromise
and make it work, there's a good chance that it's
going to work over time. I don't think I've
ever said this, I really have three major
life goals. I want to stay married, I don't want
to get fat, and I want to be there for my kids,
and I think those are just pithy ways to be like —
Tim Ferriss: Is that in weighted order,
one to three?
Morgan Housel: Probably not, probably not.
Tim Ferriss: I was kidding.
Morgan Housel: But I think that's respect
for my relationships, respect for my body, and
respect for my family is one other way that you
could put that. And I think those are really the
goals that, if I'm on my death bed and I have not
achieved those, I'm going to have some regrets.
If those are that powerful, then you're willing to
compromise on a billion different things to make
it work. And there's a friend of mine named Brent
Beshore who says, "If both you and your spouse
want to serve each other and expect nothing in
return, then it works. I want to serve my wife and
I don't expect her to serve me. And, if both of
you do that, you're always going to be pleasantly
surprised. You're always going to be like, 'Wow,
you did this for me.' You're always going to be
in the sense of awe of the other person." That
is idealized, of course. It's much easier to
say than to do, but I think it's a pretty good
guiding philosophy once you be like, "I'm in the
service industry, I want to try to serve my wife,
and I don't want to expect much in return." If I
can do those things, I'm probably going to wake up
pretty satisfied with the relationship most days.
Tim Ferriss: That's probably true for life,
broadly speaking, in the sense that reality
minus expectations equals state of being.
Let me ask you a question that I brought up a
little bit earlier. I've never heard it posed,
or read it posed, and so I'm curious to know how
you might answer this if you had a gun against the
head, because I'm not saying this immediately
produces answers, but if you had to answer it,
or answer it for other people, what
hassle are you trying to eliminate
that's actually an unavoidable cost of success?
And the reason that I want to return to this is
that, and this ties into the question of money,
happiness, contentment, et cetera, is that many
people who achieve what would be considered by
most financial success are people who have been
rewarded for solving problems over long periods
of time, and they probably identify as being a
good problem-solver. And they are therefore
conditioned, their behaviors are shaped,
to look for problems to solve, and that does
not always foster a sense of well-being,
if that makes sense. Yeah. What hassle are
you trying to eliminate that's actually an
unavoidable cost of success? How would you answer
this, or how have you answered it, or how have
you seen other people come up with answers?
Morgan Housel: I'll give you a technical answer
and then maybe a more personal answer.
I think, when I wrote that question,
I was probably thinking of stock
market volatility, very technical,
probably not where you thought I was going. A
lot of investors try to eliminate volatility,
and they view it as a burden and something
that you should get rid of when, actually,
it's like, no, that's the cost of success.
Tim Ferriss: It's the fee and not the penalty.
Morgan Housel: It's the fee and not the penalty.
That's probably what I was thinking. One thing
that comes to mind is a blog post that you wrote
many years ago, I think, about the cost of fame.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, "11
Reasons Not to Become Famous."
Morgan Housel: Yes, and you were very open and
forthcoming about what it's done to your own
life. And anyone who reads that will read that
and say some version of, "I don't envy what Tim's
going through." And the irony of coming to that
conclusion after millions of people will look at
the books that you've sold and the money that
you've made and the downloads of your podcast
would say, "I want to be like Tim," and then you
read that and it's like, "I don't know. Maybe,
but I don't know." It's not at all clear anymore.
Among the top 10 richest people in the world,
there are, I think, 14 cumulative divorces,
which is obviously a massive outlier within
there. And I think the reason why that is is
because to become very successful, you need to
devote every waking hour to your career. And
so your spouse, your children, your friends,
"Bye. Sorry, don't have any time for you."
If you read the biography, The Snowball, which
I reread recently, it's a biography of Warren
Buffett, as someone who's been such a Buffett
fanboy my entire life, and a lot of people will
fall into that category, you read his biography,
and at the end, you're like, "To tell you the
truth, not the life that I want." He has devoted
every waking hour since he's been 11 years old
to picking stocks, that's not an exaggeration,
and it came at the expense of his personal life,
his marriage, his children. There was an interview
with Elon Musk several years ago where they're
talking about how hard he works, and he breaks
down in tears and he says, "All of this has come
at the expense of spending time with my children."
And it's like I don't want that. There's not
any version of life in which I would be on my
death bed and say, "That was worth it. I made a
ton of money, but who are these children that I
had? I don't even know them." And so I think, if
you want the success, but you want to eliminate
the downsides of it, you're completely fooling
yourself. You have to make a decision. I would be
willing to bet too, although I don't want to put
words in your mouth, that despite that blog post,
when you're talking about all of the
downsides that you have experienced,
if you had to go back to before, when you wrote
The 4-Hour Workweek, you would not change your
mind. You would still do it. The cost was
worth it. I don't want to put words into
your mouth, but I'm willing to bet that's true.
Tim Ferriss: I would say it's a both/and. There
are ways in which it is worth it, and there are
many ways in which it is not worth it, and that's
what makes it so tricky on a forward-looking
basis, thinking about decisions. Although it's
easier for me now because I've realized some of
the Faustian bargains, and I've also realized how,
to your earlier point, how much money is an
amplifier rather than a savior, if that makes
sense. And, of course, it depends on where you are
on a Maslow's hierarchy of needs, but chances are,
if you're listening to this podcast and you've
made it however long, hour, hour and a half,
that using the global average as a reference
point, you are in the top one percent and
you are doing very well from a global standpoint.
I'd say a few things just to give myself a little
bit of slack, the younger self, that I don't
think hope is trivial, and that seems like such
a self-evident statement. And I'm not sure if
we talked about this, but there are some people
I've come across who are like, "Oh, lotteries.
Lotteries are taxes on the dumb," and I think
about it, I'm like, "Well, if you feel trapped,
if you don't have mobility, and 10 bucks, when
the Powerball gets over $500 million, buys you a
week or a couple of days of hope and excitement,
is that really a bad investment?"
Morgan Housel: Totally worth it.
Tim Ferriss: I would actually push back and say
it's actually probably not a bad investment,
it's actually probably a great investment, as
long as you don't overdo it. And, similarly,
I think that, without the delusion early on
that money would fix all of these problems,
it would resolve all of this inner conflict
and turmoil and insecurity — I think that
was actually a very valuable delusion.
What was my alternative? Compared to what,
I think, is a question we need to ask more often.
Risky, compared to what? Is it this, compared to
what? Is that person a good match, compared
to what? And, for me, it was like, all right,
what was the best alternative, to just not have
any hope, to assume that this steady state of,
at the time, quite a bit of suffering and
depression was going to last forever? I
don't think that was a viable alternative.
Even though I've arrived at a point where
I need to find other solutions, I think that's
better than having given up hope 20, 30 years ago.
But I would've made some very different tactical
decisions along the way to minimize some of the
risks and downsides for sure, but it's tricky.
Morgan Housel: Even if that's, in hindsight,
definitely true, I think it would've been
impossible because there's no way for you
to learn about the downsides of fame other than
to go through them. It almost would've been very
difficult to preempt it. I think there are some
things to do. Back to the $8 billion family,
they learned vicariously through other families
what not to do, and they preempted a lot of it,
so to the extent that you can learn those mistakes
from other people — and I would say reading that
blog post from you, Tim, had a profound impact on
me. And I think what a lot of people who are in
any degree of public spotlight don't understand
is that you think you're gaining attention,
but what you're actually fostering is
envy, and envy will come back to haunt
you tenfold. And so be very careful when you
put your successes out there, because even
for people who are clapping for you, they're
clapping for you while they're biting their
lip because they're envious of what you have.
Tim Ferriss: And even if they don't feel that
envy in the moment, and I may have mentioned
this in that piece, but it's the poles,
the extremes switch sides very easily. And
although it tends to be unidirectional in
the sense that the people who are your biggest,
most extreme fans, have the most dedication, are,
in my experience, this is not my own experience,
I've spoken to a lot of people who would reinforce
this, they can switch to being the most
violent, terrifying attackers very easily,
and that can get physically dangerous. There are
many examples of that. I don't have to get into
it. But that particular set of experiences has
also led me to rethink, honestly, the podcast,
in the sense that to compete — and I'm less and
less interested in competing in most things,
although, by nature, I'm very competitive. I enjoy
competing. I enjoy winning, I guess, is a better
way to put it, or maybe I just hate losing. Who
knows? We can psychoanalyze that another time. But
to compete right now, you need to, as a podcaster
in this type of format, not true crime, there are
exceptions like This American Life, but if you are
interview format, if you really want to compete,
you basically have to produce a television show.
And one, I think, of the mostly hidden risks,
which is obvious, I think, in retrospect, when
people look back a year or five years from now,
it will seem very obvious and they'll say, "Well,
how could it have turned out any different?" But
the risks of video microfame, or macrofame, and
the degree to which a much higher percentage of
the population is going to be subject to
stalkers and death threats and very, very,
very scary things, people showing up at their
homes because they bought it in their own name
and not through an LLC or trust or whatever. That,
I think, is going to be a cost that a lot of folks
are not seeing down the pike that I think is
unavoidable. For me, personally, particularly
as I shift into new chapters in my life, I've been
thinking about, meditating on, writing on, quite
extensively how I want to adapt or stop or modify
what I'm doing to mitigate some of those risks,
because I do view them as unavoidable. And I just
don't think, most people having never experienced
that, having never been in a car crash, they're
like, "What do you mean a car crash?" Like,
"Sure, I'll wear my seatbelt, but I don't have
to pay attention to A, B, and C, and D factors."
It's like, "No, you probably should because the
downside risk is so high." Anyway, not to paint
a dark picture. I think a lot of these things can
be avoided, but the temptation, like you said,
and the performative aspect of so much of this
on say social media, and the reinforcement and
the way that these platforms have been designed
to take advantage of the baser drives and fears
that humans have is remarkable. They're very
well-tuned. Maybe it's easy for me to say,
right, because I've had enough success on
say, the podcast that I could afford to pull
the cord if I wanted and do something else.
Morgan Housel: Right. And see that's most
interesting to me are the young people on social
media who are very reasonably waving their arms
to get attention because they don't have any
attention yet, and they're trying to break
through. I see this with a lot of new people on
Twitter, a lot of new bloggers sometimes, new
podcasters. How do you stand out? You stand out
by being ridiculous. A lot of new politicians,
by the way, some of whom are running for office
right now. If you're not a household name,
how do you become one by saying the most
ridiculous thing possible? So that's like
when attention is the currency and the only way
to become wealthy in that sense is to do something
so far out of the norm and norm breaking.
It's a really dangerous world to live in,
because social media came to be when I was in
my early twenties, but I see my son who's seven
and is already interacting with YouTube, not any
other social media platforms, but even in YouTube,
the influence that it has on him is astounding.
And growing up with MrBeast, which I think is
reasonably wholesome content for young people
to watch. It's not that bad. But even that,
I can see what it does to his expectations. And I
see what it does to his ambitions, and I see what
it does to his willingness to want to put on a
prank video, or his willingness to want to catch
people's attention by doing something absurd.
That is a pretty unhealthy mindset to learn
from a young age, and I think every child
is learning it today. It's just what's
being shoved down their throats in social media.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And also it's on the spectrum
of things as a male or a female, what you're
trying to do to get attention, how close is it
to say a modeling career and how close is it to
say being a professor, which are very different
things? And you could use different fill-ins
for that, but the closer you are to model or
professional athlete, right? Let's just say you're
doing something that is very physically intensive
that you can only sustain for a short period. The
longevity of that career is going to be very short
until the newer vintage comes in to replace
you, which they will. So also thinking about
what the nature of the attention is and what's
involved and what the longevity is, which frankly,
even when I was in my early twenties, I probably
wouldn't have been terribly receptive to hearing.
Morgan Housel: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean,
if I were an attractive woman, I could just show
my ass and get to the point where I'm making tens
of thousands of dollars a month for holding energy
drinks in my photos. Who am I to say I wouldn't do
it? I think there's a good chance I would've.
Morgan Housel: I think it's super dangerous
in any life to attach your identity
to something that's unsustainable,
whether it's being a model or having a certain
career, having an investing strategy. If you
attach your identity to something that you cannot
sustain when it ends, you're going to be morally
crushed. It's just going to destroy you. And back
to investing, the variable that I want to maximize
for is how long can I do this for? It's not, can
I earn the highest returns? It's, can I maintain
this investing strategy for anoth er 50 years?
And I know that I could earn a higher return
this year and over the next five years if I did
something different, but I'm way less confident
that I could keep it going and sustain it. And I
think it's the same for relationships. You might
be able to find I'm more attractive or a wealthier
spouse or partner, but can you keep that going?
Is it something you can maintain? I think I'm not
interested in anything that's not sustainable.
Friendships, investing, careers, podcasts, reading
habits, exercise habits. If I can't keep it going,
I'm not interested in it. And I think the only
way to really do that is if you are going out
of your way to live life at 80 percent to 90
percent potential. If you're always trying to
squeeze out 100 percent potential for something,
almost certainly it's going to lead to burnout,
whether it's a friendship or a relationship
or an investing strategy. So I think it's not
easy to do, and if you're a type A person,
it's almost impossible to do. But going out
of your way to live life at 80 percent has
always been a strategy that I want to do just
because I want to keep it going for a long time.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, as we're talking about it, I've
never really mentioned this publicly, but in
my experience of having various chapters in my
career and life so far, it seems like in my case,
if I'm trying to peek around corners and adopt,
I wouldn't say cutting edge, but
sort of dull edge technologies,
I'm very rarely the first. I mean, there's
some examples of me doing things very early,
but generally if you look at say angel investing,
the angel investing had existed for a decent,
actually a very long time in Silicon Valley terms,
and there were a handful of let's call the micro
VCs, but beyond that, there was a pretty wide
open field for advising and investing. And so,
I don't know, let's call it number 100 to the
field, but there was a period where the game was
kind of like Google AdWords in the very beginning.
I wasn't the first to use Google AdWords, but man,
was there a golden period three to five years
where everything seemed to work. And that's not
true in angel investing, but a lot of things
worked. I also got very lucky with timing,
but I look at that, it's like, okay, my sweet spot
was really from 2008 to 2012, but let's push it
out from 2008 to 2015. It was about seven years.
And then it became really popular. Everyone with
an audience started building VC funds and man, oh,
man, did that game get hard. Money came in from
China at one point, terms started getting really
wild, valuations went ballistic, and I was like,
"Okay, I was playing with single-deck
blackjack and now it's like five-deck
blackjack. This is a much harder game to play."
And so I stopped for an extended period of time.
Then you look at podcasting, it's like,
okay, I started in 2014. I would say the
main meat and potatoes earning potential, growth
potential was in the first seven years. Podcast
is still doing great, but I'm coming up on the
10th anniversary and the game has become very,
very, very challenging. And anyone who's being
honest at the higher end in the podcasting game
will tell you a lot of brands have been cutting
back due to global macro factors, a lot of the
studios who have raised money for podcasting, and
part of the reason you still see podcast growth,
but a lot of it is because these studios are
putting out 50 new shows, not necessarily focusing
on making the next Charlie Rose and doubling
and tripling down on single shows. There are
some examples of that, and there's some great
shows out there. But the discovery problem for
listeners and the competitive problem and
many other factors have made this for me,
again, reminiscent of angel investing.
When I started to think, you know,
part of being good at a game is choosing the right
game. Part of what makes the right game is the
right competitive landscape and the right ratio
of opportunity to cost and risk. The podcasting
game's getting very hard, and it's getting dragged
into territory because of platform competition,
let's just say Instagram and YouTube and so on
versus TikTok, this short form or video reward
system, incentive system, it's pulling people
like me or others in a direction where inevitable
costs, fixed costs, being in single locations,
which are all antithetical to the reasons why
I started in the first place. And I saw this
also with the angel investing where it's like,
"Wait a second, I'm being forced now into a
position where I'm heavily tempted to do things
that are counter completely to the strategies
that have worked for me up to this point."
Do I want to adapt and end up being one of a
thousand people trying to do the same thing,
or do I want to try something different? So I'm
just observing this sort of, if I choose really
well the shelf life for a lot of what I've done
seems to be five to 10 years, and then in let's
just say the last 50 percent of that, I need
to have my eyes open for what the next chapter
looks like that could give me perhaps that type
of runway where like five to 10 years, which is
different in a way from what you're describing,
but I'm just observing that in my own experience.
Let me ask you this, and we can of course take
this wherever you'd like. But where do you think
text goes from here? Because I think that all
that is old becomes new once again. You look at
Substack, you look at any number of these things
like, "Yeah, text has been sort of the redheaded
stepchild, wasn't sexy," but you look at the
success of, say, a Matt Levine, incredible,
right? It still works and text still travels
even though the platforms, if we look at those
social media platforms as necessary, which I
think is a question mark, actually. Text is
not going to necessarily be as heavily rewarded
as the things that they're prioritizing to meet
their own quarterly goals and so on. But where do
you think text goes in the next handful of years?
Morgan Housel: Here's what's so shocking to
me in my experience, the audiobook version
of Psychology of Money outsells the physical
book, the textbook by two to one. Never in a
million years would I have thought that because
I'm a book reader, I read [inaudible 01:43:57].
Tim Ferriss: Especially for that kind of book.
Morgan Housel: I know, right?
Morgan Housel: I know it's bonkers, but talking to
other authors, it's similar. The number of people
who are willing to get their content through their
ears versus through their eyes, is way bigger.
Reading is hard for most people. It's a slog. They
have to reread paragraphs, but listening is great.
Tim Ferriss: It's also single-tasking, right? It's
a single activity. Whereas the listening
in an attention economy where people are
trained to feel there is a scarcity of time.
Morgan Housel: Yes. And the other experience
I've had is that because of that experience
with the audiobook, four months ago I started
a podcast and I've put virtually no
effort into it. I've done 14 episodes,
they're all about 10 minutes long. That podcast
is already larger than my blog that I've been
working on for 16 years. It just exploded, which
is kind of depressing, but I think it just goes
back to the audience that's willing to listen
is way bigger than the audience that will read.
Now, I do think it's the case that not only is
reading hard, but writing is hard. It's easier to
speak than it is to write in text. So the people
who are good at it will always have an audience,
that will always be there. If you write
a textbook, if you start blogging again,
as you said you would, you'll have an instant
audience because you're good at it. But I think
there are a lot of people. Without knowing
this, I'd be willing to bet that Joe Rogan
is not a good writer, but he's a very good
speaker, and so they're just very different
skills. And so the people who can do both —
Tim Ferriss: They're very different. I will
say that I actually think Joe, if he
wanted to make it a high priority,
would be a very good writer as a comedian.
Morgan Housel: That might be the case. I'm
probably being unfair to him. That
might be the case. But I do think
they are very different skills.
Tim Ferriss: They can be mutually
exclusive, right?
Morgan Housel: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: They don't
have to come as a pair. Yep.
Morgan Housel: So there are people who are good
writers and not good speakers and vice versa. So
I think that the people who try to do both will
by and large be not that great at either of them.
And I think most people should probably try to
pick one or the other. When I started my podcast,
I thought 90 percent chance it's not
going to work. Now I'd put those odds
at 60 percent chance it's not going to work,
just because I've always been a writer. I like
typing. That's when I think I do my best work.
And so I think there's always going to be a market
for either. And the content creators who are going
to screw themselves are the people who try to be
everything to everybody. Most book publishers
want authors to narrate their own audiobooks,
and I haven't done it for either of my books,
because it's not my skill and I want to pass it
to someone whose skill it is. And it's always
been astounding to me that they want authors
who are not good speakers to do it, even
if they're not that good at it. So I think
that's an analogy for where text is going to.
Tim Ferriss: I'm laughing because I thought of
this story. Hope I'm not speaking out of school
here, but pretty sure he's mentioned it publicly.
A.J. Jacobs, who's an amazing writer. He wrote
The Year of Living Biblically. He's written many
books that I think are very, very smart.
They're also very, very funny. I recommend
people check out also an Esquire piece he
wrote called "I Think You're Fat," which is
an experiment in radical honesty.
Morgan Housel: Such a good title.
Tim Ferriss: And he said to me when he
was persuaded to read his own audiobook,
he went in for the recording session and
a few hours in they said, "Look, A.J.,
why don't you just go home, get some rest, take
some decongestants, and we'll see you when you're
feeling better." And he is like, "What do you
mean feeling better? This is just my voice."
Something along those lines. It was so funny, and
we are not all designed to read audiobooks. But
let me come back to text versus audio. And this
is going to be hard to get from any analytics,
so there's going to be some guesswork involved.
But do you value a read of, say, one of your
blog posts in the same way that you value a single
listen of a podcast episode? And embedded in this
is do you think they are the same audience, right?
Or is it like speaking at a general business
conference versus speaking at TED where you maybe
10,000 people in the first and a thousand people
at the second, but that does not mean the latter
is automatically worth 10 percent of the former.
Morgan Housel: It's definitely not the same
audience. And the reason I know that is because
every podcast episode I do, I'm reading an old
blog post and nobody cares because the people
who are listening to it did not read the blog
post. So for them, it's all brand new content.
Some of these blog posts I wrote 10 years ago,
but it's all new to them. And so I know it's
not the same. And I think there are people like
myself, I will listen to podcasts on planes and
that's it. But other than that, I just read.
When I'm home, I never listen to anything. I
just read. And even at night when I'm falling
asleep, I can try Netflix for a little bit,
but really what I want to do is read a book. And
for me, I think the reason why I like reading
better is because it's easier to zip your eyes up
and reread a paragraph than it is to rewind and
try to figure and then like what'd that guy just
say? It's easier to just zip your eyes and read
it again. And so I think you absorb a lot more
of it by reading. At least that's true for me.
I would be shocked if I deviated from that.
I think I'll be reading text forever, and I
think I'll want to be a writer forever. Even if my
podcast were to become very successful, I think I
would say, "I'm a writer." I'm curious what your
thought is that because you were a very successful
writer before you started the podcast. If you
go back to 2013 before your podcast started,
would you have shaken your head in disbelief at
the idea that you didn't abandon writing, but
you became much more of a speaker than a writer?
Tim Ferriss: I certainly wouldn't have seen it
coming. I started this podcast as an experiment.
I think I committed to six episodes to see if I
could refine my conversational skills, question
asking, reduce my stammering, and get rid of some
verbal ticks with the assumption that even if
I stopped after six episodes, that would help
me with my interviewing for nonfiction writing.
So I couldn't have foreseen it. Having done so
many interviews prior to starting the podcast, I
had confidence that I could do interviewing well,
but I never could have foreseen the podcast
getting to a billion downloads, right? I mean,
that would've been so far outside of any
mental schema for thinking about anything
that I would do. It wouldn't have occurred to me.
Morgan Housel: Tim, when you think about the arc
of your career, would you put the podcast above
The 4-Hour Workweek in terms of importance and
success, however you want to measure that?
Tim Ferriss: I don't think I would because
if I separate them out into discreet independent
pieces, I think that's a mistake since there was
a domino effect. And without that first domino,
the second and the third and the fourth domino
don't tip over. So I would have to still give The
4-Hour Workweek by far, love it or hate it for me,
blessing and the curse, that is what made
everything subsequently possible. So I still have
to give The 4-Hour Workweek the vast majority of
credit. Remarkably, that book and probably Tools
of Titans are my two bestselling books still to
this day. And I would say a third, probably almost
all of the tools referenced in The 4-Hour Workweek
are out of date. And that makes me very happy
though, because the philosophical backbone, the
core fundamental pieces are timeless in a sense.
They really don't have an expiration date.
So I've been very pleased to see that,
but it's nonetheless remarkable that the book
continues to be read and recommended despite the
fact that I'm telling people to go to a magazine
rack and use various tools to determine readership
of magazines as a way of sizing audience. I
mean, that's Model T or maybe the horse-drawn
carriage compared to what we can do today.
So at some point, perhaps I'll update that,
but that's a losing game. Also, updating tools
is just a losing game. I could have updated three
years ago and then ChatGPT and other LLMs come
along and I have to do a complete revision after
that. So I assume the principles will enable
people to find the tools. But the podcast,
I would say certainly at this point, nine out of
10 people who come up to me on the street will
mention the podcast and will not mention any book.
Morgan Housel: Yeah, that's astounding.
Tim Ferriss: Which is astounding. Nonetheless,
I do think the decay rate on the podcast is much
higher and will be on a totality much faster than
the book. In other words, not only will people
forget a given episode, they will forget that I
had a podcast or anything related to my podcast,
I think much faster than they will the books
simply because there is so much fucking noise,
there's so much. The replacement rate is so high
and people can only hold so much in their heads,
self included. So the sort of first in first out
sort of mental archiving is such that I do think
if I stopped podcasting today and people continued
listening to podcasts who were devout listeners of
The Tim Ferriss Show, I think they would forget
about The Tim Ferriss Show within a few years,
one or two years if I'm being optimistic. Whereas
I do think the books, for whatever reason,
seem to have a more persistent, enduring
foothold in the mind than in the podcast.
Morgan Housel: I wonder if —
Tim Ferriss: Even if it's the
best episode I've ever put out. Doesn't matter.
Morgan Housel: I don't disagree with it. I'm
just trying to figure out why that would
be. And maybe it's because in a book,
if it's 20 chapters, that's all you got. It's
just 20 chapters in front of you. So it gives
the impression or the truth that what is there is
profound. Whereas if you open up Apple Podcasts,
there are three million podcasts or whatever there
is, and each of those has dozens or hundreds of
episodes. It's so much in there that it's hard
to take any single bit of it seriously. But maybe
that's true for books too. You walk into Barnes &
Noble, there's a million books in there as well.
But when you're holding a book, it's like, "This
is all that's in front of me right now, and so
I need to pay attention to every word." Whereas
a podcast, it's just a living, breathing thing.
And if you watch the daily news, particularly
24/7 cable news, none of it should be that
profound because there's just so much of it.
If you're just constantly updating people on
the news of the hour, odds are it's not that
important. Whereas if there was a one-hour
newscast per year that was updating you on the
most important news of the previous 12 months,
it would be very important. You have to watch
that. It's very, very important. So I think a
lot of it is just the scale, that it's much
easier to make a podcast episode than it is
to publish a book chapter in physical form.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I agree with that. I mean,
it's spitballing ideas. I also think that if
someone commits to reading a book, if they finish
it, especially if the assumption is buying a
nonfiction book that is prescriptive in its advice
is that you are going to take action after a book.
There are a few things that happen in the process
of doing that. Number one, you're contextualizing
the book for your own life as you go. Number two,
you're harnessing sunk cost fallacy in a sense,
because you've put more time into this book,
I think you are more likely to try to take
some type of action to justify that investment.
And I would say also with the book, and
single tasking, you have captive attention,
and I think people are more engaged. This is
true for a novel versus say, a film also in
co-creating the visual experience of traveling
through these pages. And then when people,
if they take action after reading a book, that
is an extension of the experience of reading the
book and is forever associated with that book,
as are I think downstream effects of those first
steps. Whereas listening to a podcast, I think the
preset mentality coming into it, and this is true
for me too when I'm listening to a podcast, is I'm
listening to something while I'm going for a walk
while doing something else, and I am absorbing
information. But the expectation is not given
the absurd volume of podcasts out there, and also
just the absurd volume of podcasts and audiobooks
that I listen to, the assumption I think in my
mind is passive ingestion less than I'm going
to take some notes and actually commit to making
meaningful change in my life after I listen to
this podcast. I wish it were different.
Morgan Housel: Yeah, I agree. No, it is
definitely true. When I do listen to podcasts,
it's pleasure. And I think when I read books,
I'm like, "I really want to learn something
here and take notes and highlight it and read
wise and really get something out of this."
What I did start doing recently that's been
very helpful is when I'm listening to a podcast
and I hear something that's really profound,
I'll just screenshot it and therefore I have it
timestamped of like, "Oh, on Tim's podcast at
one minute and 23 seconds," and then I'll go back
and find the transcript and try to take notes that
way. That's been the best note-taking process that
I've had for podcasts to try to gain more insight
out of it rather than just passive pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: Speaking of books, so let's go
through a list, and I'd love for you to pick one
or two. We can certainly talk about all of them,
but great books that you've read
lately, Triangle Fire, Empty Mansions,
The Strange Last Voyage of Donald Crowhurst, and
then one that is a little cryptic, Robert Caro,
if I'm getting the pronunciation right,
Working. I don't know what that refers to.
Maybe we start there because I believe that is
the author of The Power Broker. Could you maybe
start with Robert and what that refers to?
Morgan Housel: Robert Caro is probably the
greatest biographer of all time. He's certainly
the most thorough biographer of all time. Most
of his books take between 10 and 30 years for him
to write. He's done biographies on Lyndon Johnson
and Robert Moses, who was an instrumental
figure in building the modern New York City,
and he's just ridiculously thorough.
And so he wrote a book called Working,
which is his life and practice and strategy as a
writer, how did he become a writer and how does
he do it? And you realize that his talent is just
patience. He will sit in an archive for 15 years.
And he has this motto, "Turn Every Page." So he
talks about when he decided to do a biography
of Lyndon Johnson. The first thing that he did is
he moved his wife to the middle of nowhere Texas,
where Lyndon Johnson grew up. And he said,
"There's no way that he could understand the man
unless he lived in the town that he grew up in."
Tim Ferriss: Full understanding wife.
Morgan Housel: Exactly. There's a funny quote
where his wife said, "Why couldn't you have
done a biography of Napoleon?" And they could
have moved to Paris or something. So he moved
there, and then he sits and he goes to the Lyndon
Johnson Presidential Library, and I think it's
literally like 8,000 boxes of material. And he
goes through every page. He goes through every
page. It takes him decades to do this. And so
there's just no one that is as thorough as —
Tim Ferriss: It sounds like a prison sentence.
Morgan Housel: Seriously. But I think he loves
every second of it. I think the hunt for him is
incredible. So even with something like Lyndon
Johnson, Robert Moses is a little more obscure,
but everybody knows Lyndon Johnson. His life
was so well documented. But Robert Caro will
find these nuggets that no one else has ever
uncovered before, and I have so much admiration
for that in terms of sticking out as a writer
and doing something different. A crazy stat
and you can take this several different ways,
but there are 1,100 biographies of Winston
Churchill, published biographies of the same
person talking about the same life. But I bet
there's like 50 of those that really stand out
because they found a different angle. They found
a different fact, or they told a better story.
Here's how I'd phrase this. Ken Burns, who does
the documentaries, his skill is telling a story,
and most of the information in his documentaries
is already well-known about the Civil War,
World War II, whatever it would be. It's
not new information, but he tells such
a good story that it's captivating and
you're going to watch it. Robert Caro,
and I mean this with the most respect, is not the
best storyteller, but his ability to uncover new
information is completely unparalleled to everyone
else. So I admire him that his skill is just,
he works harder and he's more patient
than any other writer that's ever existed.
Tim Ferriss: Is there anything else that you took
from that book that you have applied or hope to
apply to your own writing or creative process?
Morgan Housel: One of it that I think,
and I'm not saying this to blow smoke, but it
reminds me of you, is that in his interviewing
process when he's interviewing people, he would
always just stop and say, "Tell me more. Tell
me more. Keep going, tell me more." There was
one scene from the book where he's interviewing
Lyndon Johnson's chauffeur who was with him
for his entire career as a politician. Lyndon
Johnson did the same driver. And so the driver
saw everything. And Robert Caro says, "Tell me
when Lyndon Johnson was in the backseat of the
car when he was campaigning, what was he doing?"
And the chauffeur's like, "I don't know. I wasn't
paying attention." But he just kept asking, "No,
no, tell me more. What was he doing? What was
he talking about? What'd he do?" And he kept
getting the answer, "I don't know. I wasn't
paying attention." And finally, after weeks
of asking the same question, the chauffeur
says, "You know what? After campaign rallies,
Lyndon Johnson would talk to himself in the
backseat of the car, and he would say to himself,
mumbling to himself, 'This worked, this didn't,
I need to get better at this. I need to double
down on this.'" That's fascinating that he would
talk to him himself. And it took Robert Caro weeks
of asking the same question before.
Tim Ferriss: It's like a black side
interrogation just wearing him down.
Morgan Housel: Yes. But I think that's
true for everyone, and I think a lot of it is,
if you asked me what did I do last week? I'd say,
"Honestly, I don't really remember." But if you
kept asking, I probably did something that was
meaningful to me, if you kept asking and kept
pushing, then, the memories start to bubble up.
And I think Robert Caro was just a pro at that.
Tim Ferriss: Hm. What if these other books,
maybe we pick one, if you had to pick two from
this list, so Triangle Fire, Empty Mansions,
The Strange Last Voyage of Donald Crowhurst.
Or maybe you can give just a very brief,
not to leave people hanging, what are these
books? And then, if you had to pick one more,
if you could only pick two, for you personally
from this list, what the other one would be?
Morgan Housel: Yeah. Here's what's really
interesting about the Triangle Fire. I think most,
if not everyone here listening to
this knows what the Triangle Fire
is. It was a fire in the early 1900s —
Tim Ferriss: I have no idea.
Morgan Housel: Oh, okay, this is great, then. It
was a fire and the Triangle Shirtwaist Company in
New York City, which was a company in,
I think it was 1911, that was making —
Tim Ferriss: Everybody knows about
this. I feel like an idiot. I've
never heard anything about this. All right.
Morgan Housel: Okay. No, this is even better,
then. It was a fire that took place in this
shirt garment factory in New York City,
and it was in the middle of the workday
and there were several hundred, they were
virtually all young women who were making shirts
in New York City in 1911 and a fire took place on
the factory. The punchline of the story was very
tragic. I think 200 of them died, A lot of them
jumped out of the ninth storey of the building.
The building is now, I think it's either part of
or right next to NYU. The building still exists,
and there's a plaque in front of the building,
but it was horrendous. Several hundred of them
burned to death. Several of them, several dozen of
them jumped out of the building. It was absolutely
horrendous. And I think, until 9/11, it was the
deadliest fire in New York City, the deadliest
burning fire. It was just an utter tragedy.
And when I saw a book about this — I had
heard about this in documentaries and whatnot,
but I thought, how can you make a 250-page book
about a fire that, from start to finish was 30
minutes? How do you make a book? There's got to
be so much rambling in here. And there wasn't,
because actually, the actual fire was just
a seed of a much bigger story, which was,
after the Triangle Shirtwaist Fire, what happened
is all of the fire escapes in the building were
locked intentionally so that the workers, these
women, could not take an unscheduled break. It was
literally lock you in a room to work.
Tim Ferriss: Ugh. That's so bad.
Morgan Housel: So when there was a fire, they all
went to the fire escapes and they were locked,
and those women either burned to
death or jumped out of the building.
This set off this unbelievable moral panic
across the United States, of worker rights.
And one of the witnesses of the fire, who
stood on the sidewalk and watched the women
jump out of the building, was a young woman
named Frances Perkins. And Frances Perkins,
a lot of people will know that name, she became
FDR's Secretary of Labor. She was the first female
cabinet member of any administration. And she
was so moved by the Triangle Fire, as were so
many other people that, after she witnessed it,
she said, "I'm going to devote my life to worker
rights." And after a century or more, several
centuries of just horrendous sweatshop conditions,
the Triangle Fire was the impetus that was
needed to start all kinds of worker rights.
And there's a quote from Frances Perkins
when she said, "Without the Triangle Fire,
there would've been no New Deal," the New Deal of
worker rights in the 1930s that moved everything.
So much progress in the world starts
when something very tragic happens,
and starts when things are really bad. The Great
Depression, World War II, the Triangle Fire,
so much innovation and improvement comes
from those, because there is no motivation
in life more than just shock and necessity.
So the Triangle Fire, as tragic and awful as
it was, it really was the reason that we
have so many workplace protections. And
within a year or two of the Triangle Fire,
there were all kinds of new laws in New
York City about worker rights and simple things
like fire escapes and whatnot that didn't exist
until that happened. That's why you can take a
30-minute fire and turn it into a 250-page book,
is because what the Triangle Fire sparked in terms
of worker rights in America was unprecedented.
Tim Ferriss: What book or books have you
reread many times? What's in the top five list,
if any come to mind, for books that you've read
not just twice, or I should say not just read
twice, but more than twice?
Morgan Housel: I'm pretty sure I've read Doris
Kearns' No Ordinary [Time] three times, which is,
I think it's 710 pages. It's a very meaty book.
I'm very confident that each three times I read
to the last page. One thing I would say is that I
always use that book as an example as brevity does
not mean short, because that book is 710 pages and
every single sentence needs to be there. It's
about FDR and Eleanor during World War II, and
it's specifically about their home life, not the
decisions that he made during the war. It's about
the emotions that he was going through during
that period, that he and Eleanor went through
during World War II. And it's fascinating, because
you think of the pressure on somebody like that.
Of course, today, we know the outcome, but FDR
never knew the outcome. He died two weeks before
Germany surrendered. So during this entire period,
he really feels, and he's right, that the fate of
the world is on his shoulders. The decisions that
he makes is literally the outcome of humanity,
and it was as stressful as you would imagine.
The book just goes through what he went through,
how he managed stress, who he surrounded himself
with, and there's so many just incredible little
anecdotes about how he lived his life and what he
did. For example, every single evening, I think at
6:00 p.m., no matter what was going on that day,
no matter how stressful or important the day was,
he shut everything down and he brought two or
three friends into this little dark room in
the White House where he would have a drink.
And his rule was no politics. Do not say a
single word about politics. We're here to talk
about life and friendship and movies and books,
and he did it every day at 6:00 p.m. And I think
if he didn't do that, he would've lost his mind.
It would've just been too much. There's all these
little anecdotes about that that I really admire.
I'll tell you one little other anecdote that
really stuck with me for this book. On the
night before D-Day, so almost nobody in the world
knows what's going to happen, he and Eleanor do,
and he's talking to Eleanor and he asks her, he
says, "How does it feel to not know what's going
to happen tomorrow? Literally, the fate of the
world relies on what's going to happen tomorrow
morning and nobody else knows it but us." And
Eleanor says, "To be 60 and still rebel against
uncertainty is a bit ridiculous, isn't it?"
Tim Ferriss: I love that quote. She's like,
"If you've made it to age 60 and you're rebelling
against uncertain — of course, we don't know
what's going to happen. And there's nothing we
can do about it, so just go to bed, Franklin."
Morgan Housel: There's all these little
anecdotes like that. And beyond the content,
I think it's one of the best written
books ever. Like I said, it's 700 pages
in every sentence needs to be there. Doris
Kearns Goodwin is a remarkable historian.
Tim Ferriss: She's amazing. She and I
had a really fun conversation on this
podcast, actually, a few years ago.
Morgan Housel: She's an absolute gem.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, which I recommend people check
out. Also, Ken Burns, we had a conversation about
his creative process, which I encourage people to
check out. Let me ask, and then, I promise we'll
move on. This title, this is probably the one
that I would've picked up because it has, for
me at least, a very seductive title, The Strange
Last Voyage of Donald Crowhurst. What is this?
Morgan Housel: One of the most interesting people
that is not very well known—to set the stage
here—there was a boat race in 1968 that took place
in England. It was sponsored by a local newspaper,
and it was the first person to sail around the
world solo wins 5,000 pounds. And actually,
nobody in human history had ever
sailed around the world solo,
so the first person to win this race is going
to be crowned the greatest sailor of all time.
Donald Crowhurst was at best an amateur sailor.
He was a weekend warrior, and he had kind of
been a failure at everything he had done in
his adult life. He was a failed businessman,
he got kicked out of the army for insubordination,
he failed out of pilot school and he viewed this
race as his last shot at redemption, his
last shot to prove to the world that he
was worthy of their attention and their respect.
So he set sail, this guy who really doesn't know
what he's doing, he actually built his own
boat, which he didn't know what he was doing
there either. And he sets sail, and to his credit,
he makes it pretty far. He makes it halfway down
the coast of Africa. And then, his boat catches a
leak, his boat springs a leak. And he could bail
that with a bucket. It's not a catastrophic
leak, but he knows that if he keeps sailing,
he's screwed, he's going to sink and
die, because in the Southern Atlantic,
the waves are much bigger, so he knows he's done.
So now, he's like, "Okay, I can either turn around
and go home and face shame and humiliation, or
I can keep sailing and die." And then he's like,
"No, actually..." He's by himself doing this.
In his diary, he's like, "No, there's actually
a third option here, which is fraud and deceit."
What he did is, he turned his boat around and
he sailed right into the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean where the waves were very calm and placid,
and he drifts in circles aimlessly for six
months. And all the while he's doing this,
he's sending fake radio communication back to
England to make it seem like he's still sailing
around the world. He would literally send back a
radio communication, and be like, "Oh, I'm passing
the Falcon Islands. Here's what they look like."
It was all a scam. He was drifting aimlessly in
the Atlantic. His plan was to kill enough time
doing this that he could have plausibly sailed
around the world, and then, sail back to England
with his dignity intact and just tell people
that, "Ah, I sailed around the world. I did it."
And then, after six months, he starts to sail back
to England, and he realizes that the other
sailors had taken so long to sail around the
world that he's going to sail back to England as
the winner. He's actually going to win this race,
or at least appear to win this race. And
he realizes that that's a catastrophe
because he's going to get so much attention
that they're going to uncover his fraud.
Tim Ferriss: They're going to scrutinize it.
Morgan Housel: They're going to scrutinize it,
and he's done. So now, he's very mentally unstable
at this point, as anyone for six months at sea
alone would be. He realizes the jig is up. And
I'll cut to the chase and get to the punchline.
His body was never found. His boat was found,
but the only plausible accepted outcome is that,
after he realized it was all up, he threw himself
into the ocean, took his own life. And to me,
it's a very astounding story of someone who
was so obsessed with gaining the respect and
admiration of other people. All he wanted to do
was for other people to admire him. That's it.
And he wanted that so badly that he was willing
to have the six month fraud to deceive everybody,
and when it didn't work, he just decided that life
wasn't worth living. And that, to me, is just an
astounding mental state, that someone would want
respect from strangers and the press that badly
that it's worth everything to them. It's just an
astounding story of the lifestyle that you choose
to live and the goals that you tend to have. He
wanted this goal more than anyone else, and when
he couldn't have it, he took his own life.
There's a quote from Nassim Taleb,
I'm going to butcher it, but it's like, "How
interesting it is that more people commit suicide
from financial loss than from medical diagnosis?"
He said it more eloquently, but that's roughly
what he said. And it's true. Losing your status
or your internal dignity, however you want to
define it, is more disturbing to people and more
damaging to people than getting a terminal cancer
diagnosis, for a lot of these people. It's
just an astounding story of someone making
this crazy decision, the decision to deceive
people and the decision to take his own life,
for reasons that just make you shake your head.
Tim Ferriss: I'm going to act as a stand-in for
the audience, which is also acting as a stand-in
for myself. People listening to you describe
these various books might think to themselves,
"For fuck's sake, Morgan, these are some really
hardcore, dark books that you read. They don't
sound very reassuring." Now, I understand that it
gives you perspective on how your life could have
gone differently, it probably leads to, perhaps,
valuing your life, being grateful for things that
you could take for granted. But let me ask you,
are there any books that you have reread
or really love that are more upbeat,
but still decently high on the cry-o-meter for
yourself, where you're like, "Oh, God, that book
just makes me feel so good I shed a tear," or —
Morgan Housel: A book that doesn't involve mass
death and destruction. Is that what you're saying?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, exactly right. Burning to
death or committing suicide at sea.
Morgan Housel: Fair point. I have one
next to me that I'll give. This book,
it's called The Tao of Charlie Munger.
Charlie Munger is one of the most quoted people
ever, and this book does a better job than I've
ever seen at distilling his best wisdom in a way
that half of the quotes, even as a Munger fanatic,
I had never seen before. And they're just laid
out in a very succinct way that this book is,
if you're an investing fan or a Charlie Munger
fan, you should reread this book once a year.
It's very easy, basically a book of quotes.
But I think Munger is, I think he's nine out of
10 on wisdom and he's 10 out of 10 on succinctness
and saying something in a pithy way. And you
put those two things together, and he's a
really powerful person. And nobody burns
to death in the book. That's the upside of it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. Also, what I appreciate
about Charlie, which I think goes hand in hand
with his succinctness, is, he gives zero fucks,
which is so fun, especially when he is on live
TV, talking to somebody at CNBC and he's like,
"Oh, that's bullshit. It's bull." And they're
like, "Uh, Charlie..." They can't reign him in.
Morgan Housel: I admire it.
Tim Ferriss: It's so fun.
Morgan Housel: Yeah, I've talked about,
some people have fuck you money. Charlie
has fuck you intelligence, where at least,
in his own mind, he's like, "I'm smarter
than you. I'm going to tell you how it is,
and I don't care what you think about it." He
has actually talked about that. That's one of
his worst traits. That's a trait that —
Tim Ferriss: No shit. I didn't know that.
Morgan Housel: — he would not recommend other
people have that. I actually don't think it's fuck
you money. I think he had that trait when he 13.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, no, I don't think it's fuck
you money. He just gives zero fucks, but I
think it's his preset to really beat over
the head this word that I keep using.
Morgan Housel: Yeah. It rubs a lot of
people the wrong way.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Morgan Housel: And I think it also can lead to, if
I were to, even though I'm a massive fan, I'm not
just going to say he's the perfect person because
I think that shut up and let me tell you how it
is mentality can lead to a sense of egotism that
makes you blind to a lot of how the world works.
And there are, I don't know if I can
think of one off the top of my head,
but there have been a number of, this is why I say
he's nine out of 10 on wisdom, not 10 out of 10,
there are some Charlie Munger quotes where it's
like, "I think you believe that because you're a
90-year-old billionaire. I actually don't think
that's how the world works for most people." I
think Buffett is much more open to how the world
works versus the world in which he's experienced.
Tim Ferriss: Fascinating. All right. I
might dig into that separately another
times. Let's talk about Same As Ever. How has
writing this book, thinking about the content,
developing your own thinking around these
lines, informed how you make decisions? If
that's a good question. Feel free to rephrase it
if there's a better way to put it, but how has
this informed how you operate in the world, how
you make decisions, how you react emotionally to
things? However you want to answer that.
Morgan Housel: I think I've always been,
as an investor, let's focus on that,
of the view, I mentioned this earlier,
that no one has any idea what the future's going
to hold, but if you can have the right behaviors,
then, it doesn't matter. Whatever the
future throws at you, you're going to be
okay if you have a level head and a proper asset
allocation for you to absorb all the surprises.
I've never been the kind of person who's like,
"Let's predict what the stock market's going to
do in the next year. Let's predict the next
recession." I've always just been the, "Hey,
if I can manage my asset allocation and my
mindset so that I can absorb anything that
might happen, that's the best we can do."
And not only is it the best you can do,
if you can actually do that, it's really good.
I think a lot of it can be summarized as viewing
life from 30,000 feet. It's not only the best
that we can do, it's actually a really good
spot to view how the world works. And for so many
topics, I would say, "Look, if you have cancer,
you want a doctor who understands the very fine
minute details of that." But if you're talking
about investing or philosophy or politics,
you want to stay at 30,000 feet. That's as
good as you're going to get. A lot of this is
just understanding the behaviors that are very
broad and macro rather than fooling yourself
into thinking that you can understand the
finer details of what's going on around you.
Tim Ferriss: Who's this book for? If you want
to build on that, what is the audience for
this book? What should they hope to come
away from the book having learned or absorbed?
Morgan Housel: The answer to that will make will
and did make every publisher shake
their head, because they don't like it,
but it's the truth for all of my writing.
The answer is, that the book is for me. I
wrote it for me. I wrote Psychology of Money
for me. I wrote all my blog posts for me. I
call it selfish writing. An audience of one.
The reason I do that is not because I want to
think of myself as self-centered. The reason
I do it is because I think you do your best
work if you are being introspective
about yourself. And quote unquote,
"knowing your audience," that slips into pandering
very quickly. And pandering is the worst writing.
Not only is it the worst content, it's the worst
writing style, is to pander to your audience.
So I wrote this book answering questions that I
have about myself, and I wrote it in a style that
is interesting to me. And I tell stories that I
think are interesting. There's probably a lot of
death and destruction because, as you can tell,
that's kind of what I gravitate towards. Look,
in most of the world, I want to think of myself as
a selfless person, except for writing, and then,
it's just me and the keyboard and nobody else. And
I think that that's served me well as a writer,
just to stick with an audience of one, for myself.
Now, I hope and I think that I can take a leap of
faith that if I have these questions about
myself, other people probably have it about
themselves. Not everybody, you're never going to
please everybody, but that's the leap of faith
that I took with psychology and money is,
those topics were really interesting to me,
and I bet they're interesting to you too.
That's what I say. Now, I hope at the end
of both books, Psychology of Money and Same
As Ever, you become more introspective about
what you want out of life, you start answering
questions that you didn't have before about life,
and the things in the world that confuse you
and cause you angst in investing, in money,
in politics, in global affairs, whatever it might
be, you have a greater sense of equanimity around
them. Not because you have a new answer, but
because you come accepting that there are some
things we can't answer, and the best things that
we can do is just understand the broader behaviors
that guide how people react to these topics.
Tim Ferriss: Getting on the same
page as Eleanor Roosevelt.
Morgan Housel: I'm trying to.
Tim Ferriss: Trying to. Morgan, always enjoy our
conversations. Is there anything else that you
would like to add, anything else you'd
like to mention? Whether it's a story,
maybe a request of the audience, anything you'd
like to draw attention to, anything you'd like to
say at all before we wind to a close here?
Morgan Housel: The only thing that comes
to mind after having done this twice with you
now, Tim, is that most conversations in life,
I'm exhausted after 20 minutes, and I could
go for three hours with you and keep doing it
all day. It's such an honor to do this, and I
really admire your skill as an interviewer. It
makes these things so much fun. And here's what
I would say too, as I think about what we just
did here. I think half of what I just said,
I had never said before on another podcast,
and a quarter of it had never even crossed my mind
before, which is a testament to the questions that
you asked, so thank you for doing this.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thanks, Morgan. I really
appreciate you saying that. Fun for me also,
super fun. That's, I think, a testament to your
ability to jazz improv in the way that you did
in this conversation. People can find you online
at morganhousel.com, Twitter @morganhousel, IG,
that's Instagram for you folks of my vintage,
the gram, @morganhousel. And the book is Same As
Ever: A Guide to What Never Changes, which people
can find at fine book sellers worldwide.
And Morgan, thank you so much again.
Really appreciate all the time. And to
people listening, we will have links
to everything in the show notes, as per usual,
at tim.blog/podcast. Just search "Morgan," and
this and Morgan's first episode will pop right
up. Until next time, be just a bit kinder than
is necessary to others and to yourself.
And as always, thank you for tuning in.